Hello
there, gojojin.
Hello, everyone.
Hello, everybody.
What's up?
Hey, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Oh, evening, Captain.
This is your captain speaking.
And you're in for a ride.
Oh my gosh, I'm finally...
Finally!
Whoa.
Two years, Minky, it feels like just yesterday, bro.
Thank you!
Mito 1 has shot down a bear.
Watch the intro.
It's very good.
It hasn't played.
Usually, like, if you sit on the screen for a while enough,
something plays, no?
It does not play.
Space Knight, happy birthday!
And Green Bear, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you, boy!
Thank you for the super justice.
Well, thank you so much.
I'm catching Minto's dream Waster at 3 a.m.
I think you should go to bed.
I think you should go to sleep, maybe.
And drink some water.
Drink water, then go to sleep.
I think.
Maybe.
There is a tutorial.
I wonder if I should do this first, probably, not wonder.
Unless they give it to me in the beginning of the game.
Excited to see you play Mori's combat warden.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Come on, happy birthday!
Sapphire Khan got a pin with Chibi MGS3 awesome.
Awesome.
Wait, that's so good.
Tutorial.
It doesn't give you a tutorial.
Well, man, we know what we know what we are doing first.
Um, a couple, a couple of, uh, oh my gosh, oh, thank you
guys for all the supertides and man push-ups and barflays
are, thank you so much for the, thank you, do your best have
fun, oh, call signs, check in, thank you, game is a little
loud, oh, thank you, I am quite nervous, I always get very
nervous, like, playing, well, Ace Combat, I've played, I've
I played seven, but, you know, it's not a genre that I have
played very much.
But it is a genre that I'm very interested in.
So I'm very excited to get into it and everything.
And so I get nervous.
It's okay to crash, Minky.
There will be probably many crashes.
That's okay, though.
That's okay.
Don't know if we're playing awesome games.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Do you know that Ace Combat technically shares the same
universe as Dig Dug Mr. Driller?
I did know Gallagher, though it's only Ace Combat 3 that's
part of that specific universe.
Oh, but not the other Ace Combat games.
I do, I did see some people being like, what games will she
play?
I hope she plays 3.
Three might be, I guess maybe the trickiest to play.
just because, one, it's so long from what I've heard, and
two, playing the quote-unquote correct version.
I do not want to play the US version, so...
But that will be...
That will be much longer from now, probably.
I just hit the big three.
Oh, today!
now no the age of what is it the age of 30 is in demand
skewer happy birthday it's nearing five years since i first
watched your streams thank you i'm glad you're doing better
than ever here's to a bright future head thank you so much
happy birthday oh seven commander osbit not that i care they
literally cut the entire story from the us release yeah
exactly so that's why i do not want to play the the can you
even call it the localized version if they took out the
story um and the anime how can i i want to play the most
anime game with the anime in it um the gutted out version
yeah there are a lot of birthdays today yeah um oh geez uh
so i wanted to say the first thing was that actually oh my
gosh my Dragoon wife and I are finally pregnant oh I almost
said happy birthday well happy birthday to the baby
congratulations thank you for the
congratulations happy birthday in nine months um I just
realized so uh I forgot to take medicine today.
I have been playing games with only one earphone in.
Because the pressure on my right ear.
I think I don't know.
I might have like some sort of infection or something.
It like hurts in the back of my tongue.
Back of my throat.
My throat hurts.
Back of my tongue hurts.
And it has gone up to my ear hurting.
And my right ear has so much pressure in it that it's been
like distracting on streams.
with one ear button and I worry that what if I need to you
hear some what if somebody comes up on my right what if go
get take your meds I think I will take some pain medicine so
that I can at least she I can at least put it in you know
Naoko was the one to ask to get the contents cut.
It might be a budget thing, you know.
Donating a super jet so I could stop drinking energy drinks.
Wise.
Drink water.
Wait, drink tea.
Tea has a caffeine in it if you need a caffeine.
So excited for you to experience the wonderful world of base
combat.
Yes, change the screen aspect and the options for all PS2
East games.
I think I have it okay.
I think so.
Digital card.
What is with all the aquasuits today?
Thank you.
Starting again with four will be an easier difficulty curve
than starting from seven.
You think so?
Oh my gosh, what?
It was all...
You guys, thank you so much for all the silver childs, but
what is happening?
Friendly reminder that urgent care is a thing that exists.
So they don't...
urgent care does not take my ghost insurance.
And so it would be a lot of money.
me to go i tried to get an appointment and the soonest
appointment i could at the boost bottle was the end of may
so i am uh i do have a video like doctor appointment on
monday i'm kind of yeah uh Oh, it's not great, but you know.
You're playing peak.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you.
What the heck is happening?
Superliminal.
Thank you.
Trainmaster, thank you.
Non-thank you.
Son of Orion, thank you.
You'll love this series.
I know.
I'm so, so excited.
PH, thank you, Doris.
Thank you.
Whoopias, thank you, bro.
Yeah.
reform for me though i'm dead this is this is this is ghost
healthcare probably different from what you humans do swamp
gone thank you for the tonic i'm gonna trust the video
doctor he killed the radio store that guy was not a doctor
baby um but yeah uh so let me go take let me go grab some
medicine real quick so that i can take it and then i can
hopefully have my other ear button so give me one second i'm
going to no i just remembered that i didn't take medicine
today so give me i'll be i'll be right back
i thought i had put all my little metal gear rexes up but i
just found one under my chair wait so i have four extra all
right i thought i put them off wait Where
did this guy come from?
Extra Metal Gear Rex.
What the heck?
I'll put him next to my Ketzalcoatlist on my other side.
Okay.
Let me take him a medicine.
And, uh,
Sorry.
Wait a second.
My coffee was spilling all over me.
It's all over my...
My dress!
I mean, it is a mid outfit, so...
Wait!
Did that super chat- wait, did that donut just come in?
Holy cow.
I didn't- I couldn't hear it.
I didn't have my ear plugged in.
I think we're delayed.
Robin Mutt, thank you so much!
Thank you for playing my childhood game.
Thank you!
And Dwargo, I don't know if yours has come in yet.
But thank you as well!
Let's go get antibiotics, infections, and weapons!
Thank you!
No!
That's why I didn't want to say the amount, man.
Thank you!
Ace Combat fans are starved for more streamers discovering
this wonderful series.
I...
Honestly, well, I guess...
I thought about it.
I'm like, why haven't more people streamed Ace Combat?
You know, I feel like with Metal Gear, it was just as
difficult to play the series as it is for Ace Combat.
You know, back when I first started streaming Metal Gear,
all there was was Revengeance and...
And...
What's the word?
Phantom Pain on Steam.
niche i think is it really metal gear is a lot more popular
okay that's that's fair too though yeah metal gear is more
popular but i think also a lot of people do feel intimidated
by flight sims i mean i'm sure i'm definitely i'm one of
those people but at the same time i mean if i don't try them
then they don't learn them i don't i don't get better at
them you know so if i want to play all i've ever heard is
such good things about ace combat of course as a metal gear
head it always made me want to play ace combat and planes
are cool that's the correct attitude east combat is not fly
ship by the way oh sorry sorry
I want to watch the intro video.
I think I have to reset my PS2 for that though.
So let me do that.
Why am I getting dripped on by my coffee?
It's all over me.
I love planes!
Just press triangle?
Oh really?
Let me draw it.
Ah!
Thank you.
We're waiting.
And then we wait.
Ace combat four.
Shattered skies.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh.
That was too fast.
I'm gonna put in my second.
If it bothers my ear, I'll take it out.
But I'll let you guys know just in case I am playing.
And then...
Actually, okay, it hurt immediately when I put it in.
Okay, that's fine.
War is bad, but planes are rad.
So true!
They're just too cool.
Maybe we do have to restart.
I was going to say, when does it start?
Wait, can I change the camera angle here?
Oh, I can!
Look at that.
Wait, I wonder...
Okay, no, it's only with the V-pad.
Ooh!
Oh, what an angle.
Oh.
We're a little wobbly.
Did you ever consider playing Rising?
Of course!
I have played Maddie.
Thank you so much for the Super Chat.
I have played it.
But of course I don't have it on I don't have a playthrough
on this channel, so I, okay, I think I might have to
restart.
Well, let's give it one more chance.
Maybe it was... Maybe it wanted to play the demo first, and
then...
Amidst the blue skies, a link from past the future.
The sheltering wings of the protector.
Ah!
I was right.
The flames of hatred scorched the skies, igniting Gaia's
funeral pyre.
Turn that up.
Turn that up!
Is this blue skies?
A lot of people have been asking me to sing this song.
Yes?
Bird strike.
Oh no.
Look at all those birds.
A plan to burn.
Can we play as the bird?
What?
I feel like maybe some of it didn't...
Wait, maybe I didn't hear some of it because I didn't have
my other.
Did some only play in the right ear?
Just a minute.
Oh, you get it?
another demo.
That was it.
This is a short intro.
Okay.
Stop.
It was good.
But let's do the tutorial.
Let's just get into it.
So for those who missed, I'm playing with a flight stick
until I think that I am not good at it.
And then I will switch to controls.
Happy birthday!
Please shoot down at least five bogeys in my name.
Oh my gosh, Thurms!
Happy birthday!
I'll do my best.
Good luck.
Yes, I'm playing with a flight stick.
It doesn't seem like I have my yaw and everything.
Like my throttle.
And my yaw buttons.
And I have like a missile.
I feel like it's kind of...
intuitive.
It's not super, you know, it's not like a very complicated
flight stick or anything.
So I feel like I might be okay with it, but if if I am so
terrible with it, of course we won't move to controller.
Like I'm using it right now.
I think this is X.
Yeah.
Let's try the tutorial.
see how I do it.
Tutorial missions only cover normal aircraft controls
reverse and ev... No, no, no.
I think normal...
I think last time I do remember normal being like the better
way to play.
You know, like...
It was...
Yeah.
A mission star.
Okay, let's see.
Tutorial mission one commenced basic flight train okay i'm
on autopilot oh here are the basics of oh my gosh i have to
remember the basics yeah you have more control in normal
yeah oh manual piloting is not possible while autopilot is
displayed that makes sense okay take over the controls after
the autopilot display goes off okay i'm hoping that i'm
aircraft's direction actually i fear Though, maybe this
flight stick is too big for my hands.
I can't reach the missile button very easily.
I worry a little bit.
What have I just realized as I'm gripping it?
I have to like...
There's like a rest for your wrist, but then I have to be
all the way up.
Oh, take over the controls, okay.
Alright.
Okay.
practice climbing oh I didn't do that my bad hand issues
roll right roll left
okay wonder if it's this practice rolls oh no this is just a
look okay oh it did
Okay.
Oh, this is pretty smooth.
Everyone who's having a birthday today.
Hope you guys have a good one.
Stan, thank you.
Combine rolls while climbing or descending.
Okay.
We're rolling.
Rolling, rolling.
Push the...
I wish I could change the...
I don't want to be in first person.
Push the left analog.
I don't
think it's his birthday.
It's like your birthday.
I think he's super excited for the people whose birthday it
is.
There's a button to change the camera.
I just gotta figure out what it is.
Complete a left turn.
Whoa.
Gotta be so fast.
Down on the D-pad.
Okay, thank you.
Let's try it.
Get me out of autopilot.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Oh, it's not working.
Whoa, my bad.
Hold on.
Wait.
I keep rolling, but I need to like...
Pull up.
It's like so sensitive.
Tutorial might be locked.
Pull up.
Oh, oh, it's up on D-pad, actually.
I know it's, I'm, I'm like barely tilting the flight stick.
It's crazy.
R1 to accelerate.
Uh-oh, wait.
I think I have my throttle, so we're just using that.
I don't need to press any buttons.
I just need to push the stick.
But I'm going to not know on any of these, actually.
Wait a second, if I switch to controller, I'm not going to
know it.
What do you think?
Miko, happy birthday!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so...
Down and...
Fast.
We're zooming.
Wait, let's try it.
I'm trying D-pad everything and nothing works, so...
Is y'all stuck to the right?
It shouldn't be.
But yeah, I'm going right, aren't I?
Wait, you're so right!
I wonder if I have drift!
Dorgo, thank you!
Yeah, it's yawing to the right, why?
Huh?
Uh-oh.
Wait, I might have a stick drift, for real.
Oh, wait a second.
Uh-oh.
My yaw is stuck.
No!
Wait, no, wait, can I not use it then?
No, we're stuck, yaw, right!
This concludes the basic flight training course.
Mission accomplished.
Hide it when my yaw gets stuck.
There's like this lady who does singing lessons.
And the way she does them is she goes, Raise your yaw, yaw,
yaw.
And so every time, it's like vice versa.
When I'm talking about yaw here, I think of her.
But when she says, Yo, yo, yo!
I think of... I think of the plane.
Huh.
How do I...
If it's like...
Let's try...
Missile training.
I want one...
Maybe this is like a free...
Practical training.
Let's try this.
Maybe.
And see if it's still like...
Being...
Being funky.
No?
Oh, wait, Mission Star.
We're on autopilot, though.
Commence practice is just to test to make sure my controls
aren't.
I thought this would be...
Basics on how to... Oh, like, never mind.
It's not my birthday.
Thank you, though, Stan.
Thank you!
Okay, Square is the radar map.
Okay, those are like right next to... Okay.
By varying the...
Wait, change the map's scale by varying the pressure.
Oh, interesting.
I think they're all on top of me.
Uh-oh.
I think I'm in trouble.
Oh, no, just kidding.
They're friends.
The dots on the map show where enemies and allies are
located.
Maps are huge.
Awful lot of birthdays today.
I'm related, but it's my birthday today!
LRV, happy birthday!
Players the white, yeah.
Allies are blue.
Enemies are white, yellow, or orange.
We're just going to fly all over the tank.
Point of value of enemies increases from white, yellow, then
orange.
Point value.
Oh, uh...
Oh, it wouldn't let me.
I'm still in autopilot.
Wait, no!
Oh, practice.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, look at that.
It's still drifting.
Oh, well, that's kind of...
If I press...
And if I press left...
Yeah, if I press left, it is not good.
It, like, just centers me.
Oh, that's...
Wait, now it's fine.
Wait a second, now it's fine, no?
Oh, gosh.
The control...
Oh, my gosh.
It's so sensitive.
Destroyed, baby.
No, never mind.
We're still...
No, we're still going to the riot.
There's no way for me to turn around.
Because of my yaw is broken.
Wait.
I'm upside down.
Wait, please let me turn.
We're very slowly turning to the...
I'm back on autopilot.
They were like, hey, idiot, turn around.
Oh, red dot will appear.
No!
Okay, let me...
Too bad I can't use my flight stick.
Too bad.
Yeah, shogunai.
I tried.
My first time using it, so...
Oh, is it gonna get mad at me?
Oh, okay.
It paused.
Plug in my controller.
Okay, good.
Quit.
User, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Games were designed with controllers in mind.
It was a little sensitive, so...
There should be a knob under the bottom to tighten the stick
up.
Let me see.
No, there's not.
I don't know.
Let me do...
Let's do...
Okay, wait, now...
Everything was so intuitive on there.
Okay, so...
Circle is missile.
X is gun.
Square is map.
I'm relearning my controls now.
Because it was like, you know, when...
Like, the missile button on an actual...
Like, you know...
you're when you're flying a plane that's where the missile
button is so for me i'm like of course that's what i press
if i want to use the gun that's what i press oh dang now i
have to now i have to relearn everything it's okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah wait what was the bottle
Or...
Wait.
R1, L1.
Wait, then what was it?
Sorry, I gotta start again.
R1, L1.
Throttle?
Oh, throttle is R1.
Wait a second.
I have an idea.
I could just go to the controller.
Duh.
Controller should have.
Do I do?
Missile?
Okay.
Change target.
No.
Throttle down.
Oh, okay.
L2.
Okay.
R2.
Amazing idea.
Change weapon select.
Level aircraft.
Change view is down.
R3.
Rear view.
Okay.
to okay okay okay throttle up r1 okay okay okay i
feel like i should just go into it
i feel like maybe it will come back to me why
is there a very easy oh hey but this is is this how this is
this how you fly
Hard mode first.
Maybe I'm average.
I'm not average.
Normal's good.
We'll go...
Hold on.
Let me take my pen medicine.
All right.
Oh, the story.
Oh, my gosh.
That's cool.
I was just a child when the stars fell from the skies.
But I remember how they built a
cannon.
And in turn, how that cannon brought war upon us.
War was an abstract idea, nothing more than a show on TV.
As a child, I only saw it as something that happened in some
faraway land.
Until that final day of summer.
One day while on my way to school, I looked up in the skies.
What?
A sound like distant thunder.
Uh-oh.
In the blue skies far above me, contrails drew distance.
Surveying circles around in a crazy waltz.
Oh, they made a heart.
Romantic.
A battle in the beautiful skies far away.
I could not tear my gaze away from them.
It's
in turn as they climb swiftly into the sky.
They just speak up over the edge.
One flame plane fell out of the skies, spiraling and spewing
orange flames to crash by the cape.
That kid's head is all the way turned around.
Whoa!
Take him to a doctor!
now they only live in my memories of days past
the victor circled around to confirm the kill it on his
craft there was a large number 13 emblazoned in yellow I
will never forget this spares that's so shocking he broke
his neck the way the allies retreated across the ocean
before the onslaught of the enemy
Sit and duck.
September 19th, 2004.
Mission 1.
Four years after the planet fall of the Ulysses-1994 XF-04
asteroids.
Stonehenge.
The Erosion weapon of mass destruction was originally built
to defeat them asteroids.
Upon discovering its potential as an anti-aircraft weapon,
the Erosions ruled the Spanish over the mainland.
The ISAF's attempts to destroy Stonehenge with airstrikes
failed.
As a result, strategic positions on the mainland were lost.
This in turn forced ISAF to evacuate from the east coast to
North Point.
ISAF GHQ is rebooting its remaining combat forces at North
Point.
However, the Erusians control most parts of the mainland,
and they have forward-deployed bombers to Wrigley Air Base,
a former ISAF facility.
This bomber force will attempt to deal a lethal blow to the
ISAP at one point from the strategic position.
The you...
Oh gosh, it's so fast.
And the...
I can't read the text, the font.
ISAP.
Use the current SIDREP and your orders for deployment.
Oh, the SIDREP!
Effective immediately.
Enemy agents destroyed our early warning radar network,
allowing several bear bombers to penetrate our airspace.
Look at the bears!
In 15 minutes, we expect this bomber formation 50!
What did I have to pee before then?
Oh my gosh.
Our air defense forces are extremely weak at this point in
time.
Hence, our GHQ is a sitting back.
Oh no!
It is mission critical that you destroy the bombers and
utilize combat equivalents of Metal Gear.
Remember, you are the first line of defense for North Point,
and the Fea Bysaf lies in your hands.
Okay.
You can count on me!
Okay, there's only 10 guys in the air.
We can do that.
And look at all my friends.
We should be fine.
Oh, wait, but six targets.
Why does it say total 10?
Wouldn't it be 16?
I feel the need.
Easy, you got this.
Look at the membership.
Thank you.
4 non-critical Oh, okay, okay So it's 6 bombers and 4 scouts
Okay, that makes sense Okay, okay Alright Are we good?
Hearing mid Iskama, Osi is playing Something else Thank you
for the super Shady, holy cow Thank you so much for the
heart The super Fly high, fly fast Take many with you Gusto
I have no cash money, do I?
I have...
Oh, okay.
What else we got?
This is it.
It's fine.
Probably.
I can't buy anything.
It won't let me do anything.
What do I even have?
I'm selling my plan.
Alright.
I have a whopping zero dollars.
Oh.
Just tell me if the chat freezes.
It's YouTube being funky.
Let's go!
Wait.
Hold on.
One more time.
Okay.
Missile.
Missile gone.
Throttle.
Yo, yo, yo, yo.
Right.
Throttle down, throttle up, throttle down, throttle up,
throttle down, throttle down, throttle down, down, down, up,
down, up, down, up, left, right, left, yaw, yaw, yaw, raise
your yaw, yaw, yaw, yaw, yaw, yaw, yaw, yaw, okay.
Yaw, yaw, yaw, because they're the bigger buttons.
You gotta open your mouth more when you yaw, yaw, yaw.
Yeah, I'm singing the controls.
The missile got, it's because, I don't know, like I said,
the, the, the, the, the, the, the, The lightsick was so
nice.
I kind of wish I had it.
Let's go!
Paragon, paragon, and flares.
Wait, what are my flares?
Wait, I don't think I was taught that.
Uh-oh.
Wait, what are my flares?
No flares in this game!
You don't have flares in this one.
That's not a hot dog.
I've completed Metal Gear V!
I have two words for this game.
Never again.
It was the hardest MGS game I've ever played.
Really?
But it's so...
I feel like it plays so much smoother.
And no checkpoints!
We got our bombs.
Wow, look at that guy.
Unguided.
Okay.
Sure.
Flare's are cutscene exclusive.
That's so mean.
Okay.
Yaw.
All right, throttle.
No checkpoints.
Sorry.
It's going to take me a hot minute to get used to these
controls.
I'll get it eventually.
What I like to do with these games is I'll replay missions
off stream so that I can just keep practicing with the
controls.
Amidst the blue sky, oh, the link from past to future, the
sheltering wings of the protector.
Hey, Wax here, call sign Sky Eye, do you read?
Your call sign is Mobius One, who will refer to you by this
name at all times.
You are now under my command.
Six bombers on vector three, six, zero, confirmed.
Continue north to intercept.
Today's my birthday.
Victory sure would be nice.
Happy birthday!
Wait, that's what you guys were referencing.
Wait, didn't they tell me how to go faster?
I cannot remember.
Where are you guys going?
Oh, I'm stalling, I'm stalling.
Brattle up.
Oh, I see him.
Target
is bombing the city.
Oh, shoot.
Let's reverse.
Okay, just go.
What if I'm here?
Don't be over-eager in pursuing them.
Ha!
Oh, shoot.
Sorry.
Shack on the target.
Eight miles to the target.
Target.
Here, I'm gonna crash into him!
Holy cow!
Where'd he go?
Not much surface fire.
I'm going like totally opposite way.
Turn, turn, turn, turn.
I need to turn faster.
Oh god.
Why am I so slow?
There we go.
Lock on, lock on, lock on!
Lock on!
Hang on!
Landed at 11 o'clock.
This is Ellenfort.
We're under attack.
The runway and facilities are hit.
Oh, hit the ants.
Hit the ants.
Oh no, oh no, oh no!
Warning.
Ah!
Fox two, Fox two.
Oh.
I got him!
Oh shoot.
Mayday, Mayday!
Missed!
Shoot!
Yeah!
That was all me!
Where is it?
Is it above me?
Oh shoot!
Holy cow!
Nice!
Here we go.
Holy cow!
How many missiles do I have left?
46.
Oh, they give me like a million.
Miss.
Yeah, no kidding, huh?
This guy is on my butt.
Hit.
You're in gun range.
Oops, sorry.
Yeah, baby!
All right.
Let's go.
44 missiles.
Not gonna let them get away.
It's like riding a bike.
Maybe it comes back, you know?
Oh, yes.
Dang it.
Oh, I'm upside down.
I'm upside down again.
Sorry.
Where are they?
They're up there.
Maybe I'm still baby learning the bike.
Shoot it!
They're not shooting at me.
It's fine.
Yeah, baby!
Thank you!
Hoi!
We got a hit!
I can say though that I think this is going more smoothly
than the first time I played.
Oh, no, dig it!
I didn't have a lot.
No!
Hoi!
Destroyed!
Ah!
Nice, we got a hit.
Let's get this guy.
Hooray!
I feel like this is...
Oh, don't crash anymore.
Oh, no, it's game over.
We still have four minutes.
We're okay, probably.
I know these, like...
What's it called?
You're gonna get so tight, though.
Locked on?
I think we're fine.
Yes, destroy it.
Awesome.
Always double tap with...
Whoa, yay!
Hey, where'd they go?
I missed it.
Double tap with the Messer.
Yes, good advice, thank you.
Where are you?
Oh?
I don't have that arrow.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Struggling again, this guy.
There he is.
Holy cow.
Are you guys getting dizzy?
Are you guys okay?
Destroyed!
All good here.
Sky Eye, this is Alan Fort.
Got visual on the downed bombers.
Whose kill was that?
Make sure to thank him.
That's a roundup.
Let's go on home.
Yahoo!
Oh, that's a wait.
Oh, no, wait.
I forgot they do this.
That's me.
There's my wingman.
Oh, yeah.
How do you think my wingman was doing in the back over
there?
He's probably like, Minto, Minto to your right.
He's panicking.
like you know and you like trying to stabilize yourself
hands like on the windows he's like please oh no she's oh
god oh god oh she's going up she's going down a four minto
phantom so true this is me going at my little minto pace
trying to catch up to everybody there I am cruising
Yippee!
Thanks to your efforts, the enemy bomber strike was averted.
However, our victory will be meaningless should you fail the
next mission.
Oh, okay.
Oh yeah.
Rank C!
For cool.
We got cash, we got 10,000.
Buckarooners, baby.
The war seemed to unfold in the blink of an eye.
It did say triangle is a switch target.
I don't remember exactly when the forces from the west
occupied my town.
I was too busy scanning the skies day after day, waiting for
Yellow 13 to reappear.
The legend.
Yellow 13 took that guy out.
Locks the camera on the target.
Okay, cool.
I don't know.
Kitty!
Before I knew it, everything changed.
Thanks for being my flight instructor.
The language they taught us at school.
Our friendly local sheriff disappeared and was replaced by
foreign MPs.
In the beginning, some people secretly tuned into broadcasts
from North Point on their parabolic antennas.
But as time passed, the broadcast no longer came in.
No!
Maybe the satellites were destroyed.
Top to switch target.
All non-military computer networks were shut down.
Gasoline was rationed to civilians.
To drink?
Though we lived in the 21st century, we were reduced to
using crystal radios and horse-drawn carts.
Ah, the smell.
All the poo.
I moved in with my uncle in town, who used to be a taxi
driver.
Yup, gasoline.
Out of gasoline and out of work.
Oh no, the tire!
My uncle did nothing but to drown himself and drink.
If you pour enough of that in there, my act is gasoline.
I earned my keep by playing the harmonica in the town bar.
The one thing I was good at.
I'd play for selling occupation soldiers in exchange for
their charity and loose change.
This is my second Ace Combat game.
I played seven.
My uncle trash-talked the barkeep who catered to the enemy
soldiers.
But he never refused the money I brought home.
As for myself, I had a crush on the barkeep's only daughter,
who was a little older than me.
Ooh, la-la.
Another day passed, yet still no sign of the fighter plane
yellow 13 in the skies above our town.
Where are you?
So yellow.
13.
Next mission!
Imminent threat.
October 5th, 2004.
I always think of Ace Combat.
I don't know why.
I always think of it being like so futuristic.
Like, I mean, maybe just because my first...
The enemy held Rigley Air Base is located in close proximity
to our front lines.
I keep thinking they say Ripley.
I'm like, hmm, alien.
A large illusion bomber contingent.
Sometimes it is.
Yeah, yeah.
Remember to save.
Thank you, yes.
I will save afterwards.
point is imminent your mission is to catch these bombers on
the ground and destroy them we intend to turn the planes in
the air today are pretty old we got high we got AI powered
planes they got the they got the drones and seven so it felt
so high-tech you know both of you did not save after
completing a mission should I Can we go back?
Can I go back?
Will it let me save before I start?
Maybe?
I don't know actually.
Okay, we got...
7 in the air, 24 on the ground.
11 main targets.
I'm assuming that's what the red means.
Look at the old school ace combat.
You can still save if you want to.
I probably should.
Oh, I need good gear kit.
Say the game is kind.
My memory card is good, right?
Okay, here?
Red equals mission critical.
Got it.
It just looks futuristic because war.
War never changes.
I think this is like my...
I'm almost positive this is like my PS2...
not ps2 my memory card from like like it probably has my old
kingdom hearts like save files on it from when i first
played kingdom hearts it probably has like like oh what else
would be on there silent hill you know like i think it is
like i think it's i think it is because i'm almost positive
i kept the i'm i'm a keeper i like hoard all that stuff you
know Ancient card.
Yeah, there would be a fatal frame on there too, yeah?
Jose's combat fan.
I'm really happy to see you finally play this game.
Seriously, it's been such a long time waiting.
I know!
Sorry, it took so long.
Sorry to keep you waiting.
Okay.
Do I...
You guys, if you don't mind backseating me through any time,
I need to like...
purchase anything.
Because probably I would need air to ground, right?
Bombs?
Check this Rosamond.
Thank you.
You can chill on spending for some time.
Okay, okay.
Your current loadout should be fine for this mission.
Cool.
Alright, we'll try it then.
We'll try it.
If I lose, I lose.
But...
Feel free to help assist with all of this kind of stuff
because it's...
Because a keeper for sure.
Are you sure?
What do you mean by that?
Oh, it does just say air to ground.
Eminent threat.
Let's go, Babi.
Oh yeah, down a little bit.
I wonder.
I feel like maybe this would be easier for me.
I'm just gonna follow my friends.
I feel like this might be easier for you guys as well.
So.
Select us to choose your bombs.
Thank you very much.
I was actually about to ask that.
Mogies closing in on Rigley AB.
Scramble at once.
This is not a drill.
A repeat.
Intercept immediately.
Fight for this is Rigley Air Base.
You're clear to take off.
Look at this yellow one down here.
Take off as soon as you enter the runway.
I will tell you, engage.
What's that?
Mobius 1, passing over substation.
Mobius 1, engage.
Here they come.
What's a Sam?
Oh, okay, everything probably more...
Okay, we gotta go.
No, don't talk to me.
Who's taking me now?
Talk to me.
Surface to air.
That's the guy that's helping Frodo.
Jetstream, Sam?
Microsoft, Sam?
I'm abandoning my friends.
I feel like it's all over here.
Don't let them catch you on the ground.
I didn't lock on.
Hello?
Circle on target.
The bombs don't lock.
Oh, okay, okay.
Good to know.
Sorry.
Burning.
Who's on you?
Let's get my- let's help my friends in here.
I
need to- I need a tighter...
tighter turn, right?
Stick with missiles, maybe.
Stick with me, though.
Where are all the guys in the air?
Is it breaks?
Destroyed, baby.
Where are they?
Can I get this guy?
Oh wait, you're my...
I can't see.
It's too bright.
Ooh!
Oh, I'm upside down.
all right let's get some more guys let's get some more
things target uh you no no target
i'm like doing nothing all my team my team is like hello
please help oh
i'm just going up What a lovely, cloudy day today.
I think you yelled at me!
I wasn't paying attention at all.
Oops!
No!
Okay, we got this.
I took out one guy, literally.
I did not evade the missile.
I'm just going straight ahead, baby.
Keep an eye on those interceptors.
I wonder.
I wonder if I do better in third or first person.
Don't forget wingman consideration during combat.
What?
My wingman?
I'm about him.
Mm-hmm.
Wrigley Air Base in vector 340.
He's caught by seven so much more forgiving.
Obious one passing over substation.
I took one missile and they haven't, they took me out.
Wrigley AB.
Scramble at once.
This is not a drill.
I repeat, this is not a drill.
Can I get these guys real quick?
Do they even matter?
Can I get them?
Take off Runway 5.
Take off as soon as you enter the runway.
Mobius 1.
Engage.
Can I?
Miss.
It's okay.
We gotta work on the targets anyway, right?
Uh, wherever they are.
We'll ignore these guys.
Where are they?
Actually, where is...
That's fun!
Thank you so much for the five-gifted thank you.
Not well, thank you!
Is it a difficulty you get shot down in exactly four
bullets?
Are the planes made of paper?
I'm engaging.
I wonder
if I need to, like, not wait for...
We've been attacked.
We're currently engaging the enemy.
Using the enemy.
Come on.
Lock on.
Bimitone.
Thank you.
Ouch, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I wish I had, like, a health.
You know?
Triangle to select.
Will it work, though, if I have...
I think that's just to...
Um...
Rather...
Oh, oh, sorry.
Isn't that not...
Yeah, yeah, that won't give me a target, I think.
Yes, no.
I think that's just to change the target.
Ouch.
My damage is...
I'm glad I didn't.
So I'm yellow.
Not great.
It selects the target in front of you.
It doesn't now.
Okay, let's try it.
Hard enemy radar spike.
Bye bye.
It's beeping at me.
It's saying no.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, what I could do is like switch targets like that.
Ah!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Evade!
Ah!
How do I evade?
I think I did it.
She's learning.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Control tower, sure.
Oh, sure.
Ah.
Aircraft airborne immediately.
What a mess.
Drop a bomb right in the center.
In the center?
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, I'm going to go to the center.
Let's redo.
The easiest evade move is to roll.
Oh.
Hard enemy radar spike.
Oh shoot, what am I doing?
Sorry.
I kept pressing the wrong button.
Obviously.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I'm not here.
Enemy attack.
Let's get this bad boy.
We're so close.
Maybe I can shoot.
Maybe I can like, you know?
Yeah, maybe not.
I am pressing.
I'm pressing R1, you guys, but I think my...
Actually, I don't think it's actually a skill issue.
I think my controller is actually very sense... Or not...
I have to put like crazy pressure on it because I am
pressing it.
You have to hold it.
I am!
I promise you, I promise you!
I promise you!
Is it that fast?
That long I have to hold it for.
I have to push hard.
Okay.
Check your blades.
And I am, I am pressing like, I am pressing like L1 to, uh,
to, what's the word?
Turn.
I'm probably just not rid of it.
This is my second time, but he's fine.
Okay.
You're clear to take off runway 5.
Take off as soon as you enter the room.
Control for his combat 4 kind of way.
Thank you.
We can do that.
We're at damage zero.
Let's...
Maybe now with my newfound knowledge.
I can do this maybe.
Alright.
Oh shoot.
Oh shit.
I missed.
But...
Mobius 1, Fox 2.
Yes.
Target destroyed by Mobius 1.
This is... Mobius 1 is doing a great job.
Mobius 1 deserves...
Oh, there's a pizza party after this.
No, no, no, no, no!
I'm rolling, I'm rolling!
I'm rolling!
We missed, oh, they, yeah, baby.
Get all operational aircraft airborne immediately.
Yo, yay!
Let's try and get these.
Yeah.
Come on, come on.
Come on, come on, come on.
Destroyed!
Thank you.
Don't replay it!
Don't keep replaying it!
Stop!
Why?
It always replayed the beginning of the mission before.
I did dodge it though.
No one can tell me that I didn't dodge the mission.
Oh, the missile.
I did dodge the mission too.
You're the ace of my heart, man.
Just we'll send it into the ground.
It's...
We... we...
We don't!
We are all or nothing here.
I almost want to get you guys.
This is not a drill.
I almost want to get these guys.
But my friends are going to step.
I went there.
Oh shoot!
Holy!
I just took that guy out!
As soon as you enter the runway, Mobius 1.
Engage.
You froze, you'll have to wait.
You'll have to wait until, uh...
Wait, where?
Oh, white, oh, I'm sorry.
I'm pissed off.
Hit him in poor wingman!
Why not poor Minto?
We're going to be wiped out.
Point my nose to the ground.
Engage the bombers.
Box two.
Destroyed?
Good plan.
Really?
It's not recommended to, uh, you know, I'm looking at this
guy again.
Gosh.
You won't be sitting ducks.
Hurry!
Scrum on the other side!
Damn it, he's engaging me!
Destroyed.
A.A.
guns destroyed.
Destroyed.
Oh, baby!
Oh!
Did I take a missile?
I didn't notice.
The worst ever.
Did I take a missile?
I did?
Oh, I was like, how did I get that?
Oh, shit.
Go, go, go!
Okay, I think we're good.
Okay.
Just tanked it?
I didn't even feel- I filed nothing.
I'm kidding.
I might be the ace combat.
Because, uh...
I mean, wouldn't you want a soldier that feels literally
nothing?
.
Oh,
shit.
Another?
Yeah!
Okay.
Dang it!
I was trying to get Get in there!
Friend, I need your help.
Boogie on your tail.
Oh jeez.
Me everywhere.
Oh now they're the sit-and-ducks.
Okay, all right.
No missile, no missile.
No missile.
No bandit, no bandit!
No bandit!
No missile!
You
know you can just sometimes like turn your head to try and
help yourself in a situation.
Come on, please target.
No!
Target the ground!
Swiper, no swiping!
Alright, let's get a little girl.
You kind of like...
Fox 2!
Actually, it's like 6 p.m.
Let's take out these two if I can.
Don't get shot at.
Please.
Target.
Target them.
Please.
Oh, oh, you know what?
Fine.
Screw you!
Yeah!
Oh, oh, oh, dang it.
I'm missed for sure.
You don't have to tell me.
Box two.
That guy was annoying.
Come on.
More than you.
Please, please.
Who is that?
Oh, nice.
Whoever got that.
Nice.
Wasn't me.
Could have been me.
Nose down.
I'm working on it.
I gotta get in, though.
Unless there's smoke in the air, I don't care.
Okay, never mind.
I care!
I can't...
I can't get another target.
I can't hit another one.
Struggling.
Oh gosh, I'm all over the place.
Okay, how'd I have that?
I'm trying.
I really am.
I'm trying to get in there.
Keep pressing trying.
Oh.
Please don't.
Oh, ah!
I just really need to just keep pressing triangle with me.
I think.
I'm there.
Let
me try.
Oh shoot!
Oh my goodness.
Damn, they're passing.
Yeah, we got it.
Oh,
shoot.
Yeah, we got it!
Okay.
Oh, I think that's gonna miss.
Whoops, got it.
Oh, that was nice.
Yeah, that was pretty close.
If you...
Yeah, I know there are things that I can do to help with
this.
I'm just doing my best.
please no what do you mean miss what do you mean oh I think
I got him both thank you
tell them to get off my butt oh shoot
missile good all right we got five minutes five and a half
minutes to destroy like three things.
Oh my gosh, where are they, anyway?
Okay, we're fine.
Where is this guy anyway?
It's like, come here, come here.
I'm not gonna get this guy.
Missed.
Yeah, I know.
Alright.
Can I take a break?
Phantom 1 requesting air support.
Yeah, for real.
Nope, that's not what I meant.
Ouch!
Destroyed something.
I missed something.
Breaks her after the mission.
Yes, sir.
You don't got me.
What time is it?
No,
Wait, chat is stuck.
What do you want me to do about it right now?
Huh?
Where the heck am I on top of it?
Is that why?
Team, I'm sorry.
I'm so bad at this.
Free us!
Oh, seriously?
Squeeze up exhaust!
Hard enemy radar spike.
Yes.
Okay, we got one.
Good job.
Oh, turning is just so hard to do.
I miss my...
Miss!
So much work.
I'm trying, but sometimes I just gotta go take the shot.
Sometimes I gotta take the shot!
Oh my gosh, another one?
Leave me alone!
My other left.
If it's left or right, who cares?
Congrats on saving the world.
Thank you.
Is that right there?
Oh my gosh.
It's just missile after me.
No!
I was so close!
I was holding down, R1.
I was trying to boost.
No, we're never getting through mission two!
Ugh.
I wonder if I should...
The guys in the skies are annoying.
Yeah, try shooting down the jets.
Yeah, I think I'm gonna try doing that first.
Because we do have a... They give us 15 minutes for this,
so...
Honestly, I don't see why not.
You got so much better.
Already?
I think so!
That's still a bit of a mesh, but I'm glad you think so.
Don't be predictable in heading your altitude when they
close in.
Mobius 1, passing over substation.
Let's get these guys.
Come on.
Come.
I'm gonna get
you.
Mobius 1.
I'm not gonna get you.
It's like right above me.
Maybe?
Yes!
I see
I'm trying to follow the arrow I'm struggling finding a guy
Wait Don't let them catch you on the ground
Box 2 Box 2 Oh
destroy Nice Let's try and find someone else You You.
Yeah, I know.
I can read.
Oh my gosh, you really have to push so hard.
It's kind of crazy.
Am I dead?
Ah, miss again!
I'm gonna get
this guy.
I'm determined now.
Yeah!
How many more are in the...
Yeah, you, no, you up there.
Yeah, you right there.
You're mine.
Oh my god.
I really, holy cow, I have to press so hard on this thing.
Easy.
Uh-oh.
Move the ballers.
You're
good?
You're good?
Use the AA guns.
That's my friend?
Who am I targeting?
Oh,
yeah.
Where's somebody in the arm?
Oh, there we go.
Whoa!
First try!
Where is he?
Oh, there.
No booby.
He's up in there.
I don't know if I got him.
I didn't think so.
I'm trying!
I really am.
Into the sun.
I know I can't see anything.
Am I gonna have to be the only one to fight?
Take out the stuff on the ground then?
Destroyed!
That's everything in the air!
Let's go!
They're going to be wiped out!
Splash six, baby!
Oh, let your flying get sloppy!
What if I try?
Wait, oh, uh...
Shoot, what was it?
Uh, shoot, sorry.
Ouch, I'll try.
Um, how did I...
How do I change the missiles again?
Select.
Oh, I did press it.
It just didn't register, I think.
Let's do our best, baby.
Let's try...
Look at this.
Shh, please.
Oh, I did destroy something.
This one destroyed the target.
I got something.
Who knows what?
Who knows how many?
And look, we got seven minutes.
guys up in the air.
I can't figure out anything.
Oh, I got it!
I'm going back.
We've taken serious damage from enemy attacks.
What are they gonna do about it?
It's a big target.
Don't miss.
Where's my boss?
Just a couple more.
Oh my gosh.
These are so...
Wait.
Am I up so down?
Where am I?
What's the earth?
What do you mean we're surrounded by?
What are we surrounded by?
I know I should wait for Tone, but...
He's one destroyed the target.
He's talking gibberish.
He's having hallucinations?
What do you mean you're going down?
Why?
Who hit you?
I'm gonna try this one too.
Die, you SOB!
Pickle, pickle, pickle, pickle.
Pickle, pickle!
I don't know, buddy.
It destroyed something.
Oh, it destroyed something!
Nope.
He hit the brakes.
It also sp- spun out.
I get it, buddy.
I know.
Ouch, I'll judge.
Please, please, please.
Okay.
Just two more, you guys, we got this, we got this.
Just two more.
It's in the bag.
Don't say so.
Don't, don't, don't curse me.
The sky is just so...
It's no good.
Wait, where?
Where the hell am I?
How did I get so far?
All right.
This one's mine.
Bye-bye.
That's it!
That should be it!
Yep it!
Yeah, just keep turning, keep turning.
Aha!
Woohoo!
Repeat.
All our bombers are destroyed.
That was such a minimal damage.
First try every time, maybe.
You can still crash.
Oh, you're so right.
We keep going.
Yeah!
A significant number of enemy bombers were eliminated.
First try every time, baby!
And a full-scale airstrike on North Point was averted.
That's why they call her Pickle Phantom.
Pickle!
Why was he saying that?
When somebody taken his, like, subway order, they were like,
you want lettuce, ham, mayonnaise, mustard, tomato?
And he was like, Pickle!
Pickle!
Don't forget the pickle!
Pickle is radio short for bombs away.
Oh!
Oh, my hand is cramping.
What the hell?
One night, a spirited group made their way up the boat,
chased out the sullen army grunts, and commandeered the
place.
Even I knew who they were.
The patch on their sleeve was the mark of the proud Air
Force.
The proud Air Force.
A loud-mouthed middle-aged man went around, announcing each
pilot's results for the day and his running kill record.
It's already in the pickle salam, man.
For those who exceeded five kills, a thorough toasting and
soaking followed.
So me, what's soaking?
I believe it was their custom to call a pilot an ace once he
shot down five planes.
That's me!
After completing the day's review, the same guy, the
squadron agent, went on to announce...
And now, for our leader's results, everyone turned around to
look at the quiet man who sat alone, strumming a guitar.
I found myself drawn to the music from his guitar.
Our yellow 13 bagged three more today.
Yellow 13!
Bringing his new tally up to 64 kills.
Holy!
I like how the cafe sky kid.
With a tentative smile, the man with the guitar turned to me
and asked me to accompany him on my harmonica.
He's...
I brought it up to my lips and I started a new song.
I had finally found him.
Yellow 13.
But by some fluke, it was my father's favorite song.
The one he used to play at the end of each day.
So that's the guy that shot down his dad.
Yellow 13.
And he's played his father's favorite song.
Messed up.
What if I accidentally pressed retry?
It's a bird, it's a plane, no, it's a mead, flying a jet.
She's getting too close to the ground.
Team Bandic is always worth it.
Super chat.
Yellow 13 and we had from Ace Combat 7 knew each other.
The Northern Eye.
The Allied forces are retreating and survivors are gathering
at the northern port of St. Ark.
However, the radar facilities atop Mount Shesna provide
tactical support to the enemy.
in jeopardy.
Oh, uh oh.
Oh, chat frozen.
Thank you.
I can actually fix it now.
They will become a formidable force in future battles.
I'm gonna try something else.
Let me try this.
Your mission is to destroy the radar facilities on Mount
Shazna, thereby blinding the enemy and hiding our troop
movements.
Sorry, wait.
I'm gonna have to read that again, or listen to the briefing
again.
Wait, one second, one second.
Because you're briefing me one more time.
forces are retreating and survivors are gathered down the
plane that fell on a stand as well.
However, the radar facilities atop Mount Shesna provide
tactical support to the enemy.
As a result, our evac mission is in jeopardy.
Yes, yes.
I don't know what my mission is.
They will become a formidable force in future battles.
Nice.
You want that?
Destroy radar facilities on Mount Shesna, thereby blinding
the enemy and hiding our troop movements.
Whoa, okay, okay.
Got it.
Ooh.
We are in the mountains, baby.
We have six by air.
15 on the ground, but nine are our target.
Got it.
Alright, should I be good this time?
Or...
If you take good permission too, you'll get much better.
Don't be afraid of the ground.
Oh.
For ground targets, slow kill, as many for run.
No.
I think I could buy a new plane?
Wait.
Yeah, just avoid flying into the ground.
Don't be afraid of the ground.
Just don't fly into it.
What do I have now?
What is my...
Hold on.
Oh, the F4.
It is...
Everything is so bright.
I can't...
What is that?
I can't read it.
It's like the...
Can we get a little bit like a background with a opacity
like up a little bit?
It's so bright.
The readability is so bright.
Let's try buying this.
Let's try using it.
The hangar UI is kind of bad.
I honestly, I guess this is better.
It's hard.
I think the other one has a better air to ground.
Uh...
Wait, no, this is... Wait, I'm stupid.
Um, what am I looking at?
Wait.
I thought there was a tiger.
Where'd I go?
Okay, great.
It's gone.
I don't have anything else.
I guess not.
That'd be...
Godspeed, Minto.
Did you hear McQueen will be swimsuit outfits soon?
I did it.
Vegito McQueen.
This is the tiger.
Got him.
Sorry, I can't see anything.
All right.
Well, I guess we'll go with what we got.
Here comes the bomb with smaller explode radius.
Let's try it.
Let's go with what we got.
I'll just keep saving so we don't have to go through the
briefing again.
Should be fine, though.
The northern eye, baby.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's go.
It's so bright.
What were the other?
Wait, sorry.
Could I buy other bombs?
Let me double check.
Blinded by the light.
It's like I have a stigmatism.
Oh, the napalm bomb.
That's right.
Unguided free fall bomb.
Contains an inf...
Yeah.
Salish.
Put your contacts in me.
Don't buy napalm, is it that bad?
Spicy jelly.
I know, several people have been telling me not to buy it.
Napalm isn't better than what you have.
Good to know.
Let's just go with what we got.
F4.
War crimes!
No!
Game's so authentic, it's designed to be played with flight
goggles.
Literally, I'm flying how often am I flying to the sun.
This combat area is within enemy airspace.
Keep an eye out for bandits.
Use vector 180 to return home.
Is that the moon?
Wow, what a beautiful day.
Sorry.
Clear to engage.
We're like close to the mountains here.
I don't know if I'll get that.
Radar base one.
Red vector three one zero eight miles.
I'm counting on you.
I'm being?
That's a misstatical.
Oh, they are so close to the mountains.
I might want to do first person mode for this because...
It's like so...
Wait, where'd he go?
Nothing but air.
Heads up.
No, there's all... Got it.
Yeah!
Stick with Minto and you'll make it!
Yeah, baby.
First person might be easier for this.
Oh, nice.
You took my kill!
Did it took my kill again?
Actually, I think I would have missed that anyway.
Yeah, I missed because he was freaking dead.
He was already gone!
Missed.
I see him.
I want that guy.
He's so tough.
Oh, maybe I should have...
On the other way.
Please!
Ah!
I'm stalling!
There he is.
Can't get this guy.
Hi!
Oh!
Wait, did someone take him out?
My friend!
They did what I could not...
Dang.
I suck.
Am I needed on this team?
It might be useless.
Obious one, box two.
Good
job, Obious one.
Let's get this guy.
High F-16.
Oh, wow, that's a scary view, isn't it?
That's a scary camera angle.
Box two.
Maybe.
Yes!
Beautiful!
Are you guys proud of me?
Let's get that guy started.
Yeah!
Come on.
Nice.
Please.
Yes!
I might be too good!
Wait, I think my Ace Combat 7 training is really playing off
right now.
I think so, I think so!
Wait, is there more over here?
Maybe I should grab these squares.
Right?
No one's getting this.
Hold on, let me...
We gotta get these first, no?
Before I...
It's like riding a bike?
I don't know about that, but...
Imagine what it would be like...
I think with the stick it would be...
I mean, it's already pretty jerky for me, but...
Mmm, jerky.
But it would be much jerkier, probably.
Can you lock on, please?
Can I get towed?
I don't think.
I gotta get these.
What's Fox 2?
Like, is that somebody?
Or are they like saying that there's more back, like two
bandits or something?
Fox 2.
This is Paul's son.
Okay, that's what I thought.
Target destroyed by Mobius 1.
Yeah, we gotta get the...
Everybody just left.
Left over here!
Oh!
What should be?
Fox 2!
Take out.
I can't even see where the heck it is.
Am I blind?
I think I'm like flying right over it though.
Why?
Where the hell is it?
Okay, I'm switching.
Switching views.
Yeah, I'm like right over it, aren't I?
Okay, hold on.
Oh, it's stalling.
I'm stalling.
There it is, there it is.
Okay, I wanted to get those before we went too far away.
Yeah, I needed to line it up, but it was...
Sometimes I feel like the, uh...
What's it called?
It's like...
The mini-map feels confusing.
Good job, thank you.
Okay.
All right, let's go get the rest over here.
We're zooming.
We're zooming over.
What's going on?
Who is that?
Who was that?
Hopefully none of my friends.
Wait, is it all on the ground?
Yeah, all ground.
Box 2 is launching key cities.
Box 3 is radar guided missiles.
All you're saying.
I gotta go out a little bit more.
Oi!
Well,
Vintas enjoying his combat!
I am!
Hello!
Alright, you.
Right there.
Give me tone, give me tone, give me tone, give me tone, give
me tone, give me tone!
Give me tone, give me tone!
Give me a tone!
Thank you.
Target is neutralized.
I think I gotta go a little bit more.
The second mission definitely felt like, uh...
Relearning?
Relearning the game a bit, you know?
Oh, shoot!
I had it!
No!
I think I lost it though.
I was gonna... I was gonna do the other...
Playground to get the moves back.
Yeah!
Let me try.
It's so hard seeing these dang things.
Let's try this.
Wait!
Oh,
okay.
We're going back to the east.
What is my team doing?
Friends!
Oh, I'm stalling again.
Friends, we need to engage.
Come on.
Friends.
No, please change the target.
Yeah.
Surface target destroyed.
Good job, homie's one.
Mission update!
What do you mean, update?
Fighter squadron here.
Mission accomplished.
We're done.
Are we...
Is somebody coming in hot?
Sky Eye here.
Radar facilities confirmed destroyed.
Yeah!
Uh oh.
All aircraft take vector one eight zero south.
You can...
What what?
Loop for your plane, your plane in vertical.
Use the return line on the map to exit combat area and
return to base.
Where my friends are?
Fly in the right direction and you'll see a white dotted
line across your flight path.
Am I?
Where's my friends?
I'm just gonna follow them.
Those of you who need to resupply or refuel during missions
should cross this line to exit the combat area and return to
base or carrier.
for like two seconds.
Uh...
Hello?
Mobius 1, you're heading the wrong way.
Vector 180, south immediately.
There's no line on my map!
Just go south?
Which way am I headed?
Wait, eh?
It's zoomed!
Press the button heart!
Oh, there we go!
Oh, so I have to...
Oh, okay.
Uh, I have to pass this line.
Oh, my gosh.
This way.
Sure.
Yeah.
Easy peasy.
A true ace!
Approaching return line.
Follow the controller's orders for landing.
Oh, no.
Wait.
I have...
Oh, geez.
I forgot how to do these.
No, I'm the ace.
I'm the ace.
Return to carrier.
I am.
Oh, did you pass flight school?
That's the fun part.
I never went.
Perform landing check.
You are cleared to land.
Oh, shoot.
No, no, no.
Okay.
Wait, I'm not stalling.
I'm coming in hot.
I'm not coming in hot.
one mile to touchdown oh my god please oh jeez wait no don't
don't go you're on the money pull up your altitude is too
low uh ah uh oh shoot one more try sorry you're beyond
instrumental guidance limits do a visual touchdown
oh okay okay Guys, can I just skip the button?
Can I just skip?
Turn left.
Okay, I will.
After I get some...
Oh my god.
Oh, my button, I mean, my hand slipped.
That was so crazy.
With their radar out of commission, the enemy's command and
control is degraded.
The evac and regrouping efforts are proceeding as scheduled.
We'll get them next time, boys.
We'll get them next time.
I was scared that I would die and have to redo the mission,
okay?
I was scared that I would have to redo the whole mission if
I died.
I was scared.
Fair.
You don't have to redo the whole thing.
Oh, I wouldn't?
Oh, well, if I knew that, then I would have tried.
Once you're on landing, you're in the clear.
We've discovered the Eurasians are transporting a large
quantity of strategic supplies and rapid deployment troops
into Comberth Harbor.
Comberth appears to be the staging area for an attack on
North Point.
The Acre Fleet stationed here seems to be the centerpiece of
this strike.
If the Eurasians complete their troop preparations and the
Acre Fleet sets sail, This will bring about our defeat in
this war.
Your mission is to intercept and shoot down the enemy
transport planes in and around combat armor.
Yeah, if you don't complete this, we're all dead.
We're showing how vulnerable they are.
Be advised, the transport aircraft have ECMs on board that
emit powerful jamming signals.
Remind on visual contact rather than radar.
No pressure.
We got 11 guys in the air, but our target is three of them.
No problem!
Peak BGM incoming!
Easy probably.
I'm gonna do a second save just in case something happens
with the first one.
You know.
Corruption and all.
Can I buy any more plane?
Oh!
Oh god the F-16!
Shall we?
I'll buy an F-16 just for this mission.
Hold on, I can't read.
Okay, I'm trying to see, like, the...
There's the other way.
Yay!
Let's see what...
If we have any other...
For my F-16.
16, yes.
Air to ground.
We don't need that for this mission.
Advanced air to surface, missile, fire, and forget weapon
capable of hitting up the four targets at once!
Boy, yeah.
Yeah, I can't afford it, though, Shad.
Wait, we do need air to ground.
I thought I said zero on the ground.
Am I crazy?
I thought I said zero.
Two four.
yeah not this mission I reject your one guy I reject you you
say you say you say you need ground I reject I say I will
not be one guy today
I'm double checking now I'm scared
let's get up we've discovered the Eeroge it's all the way
over there menacingly we're getting closer oh my gosh scary
you reject the ground yeah well i'm gonna go so i like float
a lot not always but if the eruptions complete their troop
preparations and the agar fleet sets sail this will oh wait
so it is like your mission is to intercept and shoot down
the enemy no yeah i'm shooting down the transport planes so
it's not the ships let's I'm shooting down the plane, not
the ships.
What's an ECM?
It makes powerful gems.
Oh.
Visual contact rather than radar.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, there's no naval, no ground, all air.
I was right.
Electric countermeasure.
Evil?
How dare they?
I thought we were playing a fair fight here.
I'm gonna do a...
That's fine.
Alright, let's go.
Wait.
Let's go with my F-16.
Yes.
Look how skinny she is.
Dang.
It's always so hard though, getting to like, uh...
When you...
Block it.
When you get a new plane and you have to learn how to, you
know?
Sky Eye here.
You should be getting visual on the transport soon.
Destroy the E-767s hidden nearby to clear the gem and follow
here.
Holy fast.
Good luck.
Okay, I see them.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
I'm decreasing my throat.
I have fly support on this aircraft.
Oh, oh, my friends are passing me.
Now you want to engage.
Oh, but I see that's probably like the radar, right?
Oh, I see.
Oh, interesting.
I see how it is now.
Okay, okay.
I'm engaging.
I am!
I will.
Once a...
Holy cow, though.
Say your prayers.
Well, I...
Be able to...
Hard enemy radar spike.
Will I... actually will it be able to lock on?
Oh shoot.
Two targets for me.
Target destruction confirmed.
Uh, I'm seeing the sun.
I'm spiked!
Get him off me!
Good dodge.
I got him and I dodge.
He's not kind of crazy.
Where is it?
Over there?
I
want that target down there.
Oh
shoot, I was too.
No!
Nice shot, thank you.
There you go.
There he is.
Radar lock.
Box two.
Kaplowie!
Good job, Mogul.
What?
Oh gosh, wait, I tweeted about this yesterday, but...
Oh my gosh, I keep getting these like...
These TikToks of like some person who...
Where's the other target?
Behind me.
Hold on, I'll have to explain.
This is Spider-Man.
Rip my grandma.
I'll talk to you later.
Yes, baby.
I am on fire.
Can I destroy them?
The
music is so good.
Thank you.
You did it!
Yeah!
Easy peasy!
and I was talking okay so there's like these they'll be like
there's this person that keeps making edits of this one song
that's just like rest in peace my grandma she got hit by a
bazooka kaboom ka plow um and someone keeps making edits of
that song but with aunt may from spider-man but they like
also change the song to be like it'll be like there was a
lincoln park one that i saw that was like i tried so hard
kabooka plow rest in peace grandma bazooka i couldn't stop
watching them last night i was cracking up
skipped osg speedrun sorry i was really locked in there the
mission was a success i was really locked in for that
mission.
I kept like, I kept like not missing.
Did you guys see that?
Maybe I'm really awesome with the F-16.
The brain rot.
It's been a while since you cranked up.
Preston Peace, my grandma got hit by a blockade.
Kaboom, kaplow.
It's way more agile.
Yeah, it felt good to use.
Clean intercept.
Thank you.
If you want S-Rank, you'll need to take out the fighters
first, though.
Oh, it's okay.
I'm not sweaty about games.
I don't really care about ranks.
F-15 active is the best plan.
IMO, really?
B for boo.
B for binto.
Ran three miles to the stream.
Let's go see more.
Let's go.
S-Rank gets you more money, though.
I know.
but it's all tough.
Never in a million years would have guessed Minta Playmate
Base Combine.
Isn't that strange?
I feel like I loved Metal Gear so much.
The complex consists of a base-based oil refinery storage
facility and an offshore oil drilling platform.
Your mission is to go out and destroy or at least damage
these sites.
Just damage them?
Our objective is to reduce production output in this complex
to 20% or less.
By cutting off the port's fuel supply, we will delay and
disrupt the combat component of the aviator fleet.
Hmm.
I think planes are cool though.
It really, this is like, I feel like this genre feels really
satisfying when you get good.
You know what I mean?
Like, Holy cow, 88!
On the ground?
That's crazy.
Like, when you get good at, like, uh...
Air... Air game.
It feels good, yeah.
Feels good to get good as you go.
I mean, they're tough, though.
I'm not gonna lie, they are tough games.
At least for me.
But I think dogfighting is so fun.
I really like the air-to-air combat, so...
Aeroge?
Flight Sims, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Flying is fun.
Cool, military games that aren't standard FPS.
Maybe that's why I like Metal Gear 2, because it's not FPS,
like it's...
You know.
Kind of...
Take it at your own pace.
Aerogei.
All right.
There's so many little guys on the ground.
Okay, this is the only one I got still.
Wait, let me see how it's...
Oh, wait, maybe I can put in my second earbud now.
Go, go, go.
This...
Oh, in my left ear, all I could hear was that bass.
Oh,
like, oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, should I try this?
Damn.
And it's homing.
And a multi-target.
I feel like this would be great for all the ground stuff.
Yeah?
Okay, that's what I thought.
It's a good option.
I thought so.
I will, though, ask you guys every time.
It is only 12 ammo.
But it destroys four targets in one go.
So if they're all clumped together.
I could always rearm.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If I love it the series like I and so many others have.
Oh, thank you so much, Marco, for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
You still have regular missiles.
Yeah, I know.
I use those too.
I switch.
I think.
The first one though, I couldn't aim it very well, so...
I couldn't aim it so well.
I feel like maybe it's better to...
Whatever, it's fine.
Let's just do the loadout and I can always change.
It's no biggie.
This one does not have great air to ground, but...
Oh, they're both about the same.
So we'll stick with the F-16.
Those who know use guns.
But my aim.
You can refill your ammo by crossing the line.
See?
I
get 14 of the UGBs.
I'll try it.
I want to try something now.
Gun is hard to use in Ace Combat 4.
all right let's try let's try lifeline oh that game score at
least 2 000 points within the time limit and continue to oh
it's one of these types of missions okay and continue to
destroy enemy forces okay so 2 000 points and just keep
blowing up got it
why is it so dark split into two groups and destroy targets
two groups Which friends do I like more?
Um...
Friends, I'm going with you!
This is the real thing.
Eh.
We'll be seeing a welcoming party any minute now.
Okay.
Alright, friends.
Heads up.
They've got AA guns.
AA guns.
AA Ron.
Keep an eye out for Sam's.
I got the oil rig.
Clear to engage.
Okay!
Oh.
Wait, they're like right on.
Oh my gosh.
Omega 11, engage.
Mobius 1, engage.
I am.
Oil rig.
Speed up a little bit.
Those interceptors are pesky.
They are pesky.
It's okay.
I'm on him.
Yeah.
Eject!
Oh shoot.
Missed?
I know.
Wait, where'd he go?
Your tail!
You're gonna be going home with your tail between your legs!
Oh shoot.
Ah, that was bad.
Wait.
I still got radar, though.
Miss again!
Wait.
Where is he?
Oh, he's, like, on me, too.
Do these guys count for...
For points?
I sure hope so.
Yeah.
Where did my friends go?
I did.
Yeah, I was diving.
That's okay though.
We made it.
We lived.
No biggie.
Any points count.
Oh, we're at the oil rig!
Oh, that's... So that was us!
Let's go.
Damage, damage, damage.
I destroyed something.
Yeah!
We love destroying 8A guns.
Bandit closing at 6.
No, no, no.
Okay.
Uh, let's get some fighters, let's get some bandits out of
the air.
Where is he though?
Oh.
Engage and destroy all pop-up targets.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Hold on, I'm gonna...
No.
Hard enemy radar spike.
Thanks for the save.
Sorry.
Okay.
I need this guy off my butt!
Hard enemy radar spike!
Deflect?
Where is he?
Just don't get shot down.
Hard enemy radar spike.
Locked on.
Fox 2.
Miss.
No, I think that's a miss again.
That's a miss again.
Locked on.
Release.
Ah!
This game is hard to see.
Because the ocean looks so similar to the ground, you know?
Or like everything just...
The ocean looks so similar to the sky, I mean.
Where are you?
Hello?
There we go, maybe.
Ah!
So close!
Yeah, it's all gray blur.
Oh, shoot.
That's not gonna hit.
Ah!
That's fine.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do!
Shoot.
We'll do this.
Or not.
Music is so good.
Holy cow.
USLV!
It's fine!
I just get confused with the select and the down- don't ask
why.
Don't ask why.
Why?
It just happens.
I should probably focus on
some more...
Getting some more points.
I want to get, like, halfway there or something, you know,
at least.
Uh...
I only have one left, though.
Now we're out.
Did they get this guy yet?
I'm not gonna go all the way out there for this guy who the
heck is Sierra oh damn I wonder if I could just start
shooting yeah that guy is so far away sure
sure oh oh pull up pull up yeah my friend is my friend is
Trying to...
Wait, my friend is like right here.
Where is this bandit?
Oh, I think he got him.
Good job!
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Shoot.
I can't even tell if I'm doing damage when I use my gun.
Maybe we go to the next area.
Why are you going down?
Oh, there's stuff like everywhere.
Three minutes!
Oh geez, yeah, you're right.
Okay, I'm halfway, but I only have three minutes left, so...
Maybe I go find some more... What the?
Wait, um...
Where is this guy?
Over here?
He's like right above me.
I'm flipping... I'm flipping overwards.
There's more bandits at least.
I could try.
I get...
Maybe... I don't think I'm gonna be able to get these ones,
man.
I'm so bad at these, like, point ones, I feel, because I'm
not a very fast person.
This guy's kind of far, but...
Two minutes, I know!
I don't think we're gonna make it, wait, maybe we can...
We did so much damage!
I wish we could get more missiles.
I think going all the way...
Are we cooked?
We might be.
I was gonna try and go to the other area, but I think I'll
be just as slow there too.
You can get more missiles.
I think I should try.
But I only have a minute then.
I think I should- I'm gonna retry.
It's okay.
I'll keep trying, obviously.
But...
I think it'd be better for me to just restart.
Yeah, I won't make it.
I won't make it.
That's okay, that's okay.
I'm like- I was kind of like lost in the sauce for a second.
So it was like, oh, oh, oh.
Need to be more aggressive.
I know that's my issue with these.
It's because I'm still like trying to learn the controls a
little bit.
So it's like harder for me to be...
I cannot see.
I don't know if I'm up or down.
It's actually so confusing.
And I also can't tell how close I am to the water.
So it's a little...
I'm so lost in the sauce here.
Eh.
That's okay.
Ah!
Focus on the altitude meter.
Yeah, I guess that would help, huh?
Ugh!
Commence operation.
Split into two groups and destroy targets.
Inflict as much damage as possible to the ground level.
Actually, let's try the other way.
We tried one way.
Let's go with my other fringe.
Be calm and give it your best shot when the enemy arrives.
We're out of my fringe.
Do a flyby under the oil rig.
Are you sure this is smart?
We're over the bad guys.
I've... The bandits give you like no points.
I guess...
Ugh.
Ready guys.
Fight for nine.
Engage.
one engage i don't think that's gonna hit refinery if i
didn't think so
no stay on your toes enemy sam's are a factor did my friends
just leave come on come on Thank you!
Miss!
Have you played any Star Fox games?
I haven't.
I've not played Star Fox.
Oh, I don't know if that will.
Oh, so close.
Maybe now?
Yeah.
Alright, so this way.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Oh, I'm like, hi.
Oh my gosh.
All right.
I've got enough to sanitize my six o'clock omega five.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Are these gonna make it?
Oh.
Take out the fighters first.
Got it.
Oh,
come on, come on, come on.
No.
I think I can get him now.
Get him now, get him now.
Yay!
Oh, please, please, please, please!
Please!
Trashed.
My bad.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh, where is this guy?
My health too.
Okay.
Wait.
Where is he?
Wow, we uh...
Not to kill!
No, my friends!
Where are the...
Thanks for the save!
I'm going down!
Enemy facility destroyed!
Use the gun!
I tried!
It didn't do anything!
Come on, baby!
Daddy beats her bullseye!
Yeah!
No!
Please!
Come on!
Oh, I got a hit!
Just one more?
Yeah!
Okay!
all right oh there
is oh my gosh please please please ah my altitude I'm
going all cookie I'm getting cookie I'm getting cookie box
two enemy facility destroyed I'm not It's not even halfway!
I'm getting kooky!
It's so hard to see.
At least this one's easier, but my goodness.
When I get kooky, I get kooky.
Alright, let's try like gunning stuff down too.
Maybe here would be easier.
Hey, am I good?
I think I'm good.
My altitude is like crazy right now.
I'm not ignoring greed.
It's not locked on.
Why would I shoot?
If I've got a miss.
Please.
It's a miss.
Wait, I missed?
Fox 2.
The third one.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Okay.
We got about three and a half minutes.
Right beside you.
Great line.
Thank you.
Fox 2.
All right.
Any more over here?
Yes.
Oh, there's more in the sky, too.
Where'd you come from?
I'll get him in a second.
I'm just going through.
I'm just going through and, you know, taking care of these.
Oh, dang it.
I have the...
I had...
We got three minutes!
There's a couple more here?
I think there's more over here.
Yeah, yeah, okay, over there.
I'm letting them handle everything.
I'm just taking out these things.
No worries.
You know?
Come on.
Give me time.
On the last one.
Please.
Ah, I think I missed it.
Oh, we're so close.
We're so close.
Don't let you fly and get sloppy.
I'm trying not to!
I'm not?
Uh, where is it?
Dang it.
I think this is like the last one here, too.
Wait, this sucks.
Made five missiles left, I know.
Wait, uh...
Okay, hold on.
Let's, uh...
Let's do this.
Wait, there are some guys!
Holy cow.
Oh, shoot.
Maybe we can get these guys.
Wait, I'm like all by myself though.
Not yet.
Alright then.
Hard enemy radar spike.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Oh gosh.
I just need like one, two more guys.
Maybe?
Fox two!
No!
Please!
I think I missed.
Come on.
Friends!
Friends, I could really use your help right now.
Oh my gosh, please.
Please!
Oh my gosh, get off my ass!
Oh, I only ever made it!
This is so bad!
Ah!
Bandits!
Mobius 1 crashed!
It's okay.
Splash landing.
NTNT!
Leakal.
But that was definitely the easier...
That was the easier area, so we'll go back that way.
I don't know why.
On the other side, just kind of...
Damn it, I ain't going home with a body bag.
Hey, don't run into me.
They've got AA guns.
Refinery.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I'm like going totally wrong way.
Where am I?
I wish I wouldn't just lock onto a random target.
Wait, where am I?
Guys, I'm lost.
Wait, I'm lost?
Are you sure this is smart?
We're over the bad guys.
There we go.
I was lost, for real?
Wait, where are they?
Yeah, let's not do that.
I see flames.
Are you guys below me?
Heads up.
Enemy radar spike.
There they are.
There's somebody at least.
Holy cow.
You think I should ignore them?
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
I don't even know where the hell I am, though.
This is so confusing.
I can't tell what the hell I'm looking at.
Am I looking at the sky?
I'm going this way.
Oh!
Get me out of here.
Warning missile.
I'm going the wrong way.
You guys got...
Okay, I'm going to retry.
That was clearly...
That was not good, right?
That was not the run, everybody.
Let's retry.
They were on me.
Commence operation.
Split into two groups and destroy targets.
All right.
I'm going to ignore those guys.
My friends can take care of them.
Oh.
Yeah.
Keep an eye out for Sam's.
Sam's.
Frodo.
That's what Smeagle would say.
Keep your eye out for Sam.
Now she's thinking like a horseback.
I think honestly when I do get like so crazy.
Oh my gosh.
I can't.
I don't know why I keep thinking select is to change my
missiles and then I mean sorry select is to change my POV
and then I'm changing my missiles is the town button
Refinery Redbecker 300 12 miles Mobius 1 engage I'm ignoring
these guys I'm ignoring you Those interceptors are testing
you following my friends They're sitting just Following my
friends I'm ignoring you Red Vector 310.
8 miles.
Can you swap button layout?
No, I think it's better if I just learn.
You know?
I think it's better if I just get it.
Get it.
Oh my god.
See, I just did it again.
I just did it again.
Maybe I should switch it.
Maybe I should.
Enemy facility destroyed.
It'll just take some getting used to.
Yeah, pretty much.
Come on.
Hello?
Oh, I took that!
No!
Please lock on.
I don't know why he's not locking on.
There we go.
Don't know why he's not locking on.
Did I get anything there?
Shoot.
Please.
No!
I
don't know guys.
I don't know about this one either.
I'll try though.
I'll try my bestest.
I always try.
I always try my bestest.
Who's on my butt?
I destroyed!
I destroyed with...
with my guns!
flying too low is that the issue
I'm not even halfway and it's still seven minutes oh geez
okay refinery you're going down these guys are I can tell
they want me to these guys want me Dead.
Oh shoot, I forgot to set this to the second one.
Aha!
Oh, oops, there we go.
Where is he?
I think I got him.
Yeah.
Leave me alone.
I'm working.
I'm doing my job.
Two parallels to the ground.
Come here.
Yeah, just a little more.
Come on!
Eh?
Enemy facility destroyed.
Box two, box two.
It's not bad.
It's working.
Okay, where are you?
Let's try.
Get that guy.
The bandits, where are they?
Where are you?
Oh, there he is.
up there.
Where is he?
He's on me.
I think I managed to evade him maybe?
With my very...
He was like, what the hell was she doing?
I've never seen those moves before.
Miss!
Ah, I lost him.
Oh shoot.
Okay, I got 25.
I know!
I know I missed!
my friends!
The 5 million barrels!
I've never seen such technique before!
It's so it's so innovative!
I'm gonna run out of... Oh, we got him at least finally.
But I'm gonna run out of missiles at this point.
Where is everything?
It's down on the ground, right?
Too high up.
Oh!
Oh my god, oh my god.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Every time I try to get lower, I point my joystick up on
accident.
You know?
I
don't think I can get enough in three minutes.
I'm too bad at the- I'm too bad.
Maybe.
19.
You can do it, Minky.
I'll keep trying.
I'll keep trying!
That's what you get for coming at me.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Mobius 1, box 2.
Smoke in the ear.
Enemy facility destroyed.
So close.
I think I have to get this guy.
He's going to...
Oh, wait.
That guy's really far away.
Just kidding.
Where?
That might be it.
This might be it.
No, so close.
I have to get this bandit.
Please, please, please.
Oh, so close.
Oh, dang it.
I should have shot.
I know, I know, I know.
I think so, maybe.
Come on, come on.
We need to kill it!
Oh my god.
My heart is pounding!
Holy cow!
Shoot!
I remember, though, when these missions really used to,
like, take me a long time.
Like, take me many, many times.
So, I'm happy that I can...
Maybe I've improved a little somehow.
Nice kill.
A true ace!
I'm...
lost in the sauce again.
Ah, we did it!
Somehow!
Do I need to go back to the line?
Oh, there's one heavy group.
Hot appears to be five targets in the group.
Oh.
No.
Oh, no.
Now run?
Am I going the right way?
Once
again, I could not tell.
We're just going.
Follow the green arrow?
I don't think so.
I don't think the green arrow is telling me to go.
As they said south.
That's where I'm headed.
That's the yellow squad.
Now I've seen them with my own eyes.
They're pushing and flying out this far.
Oh yeah, do not follow the arrow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going towards the line.
I am going towards the line.
As I was instructed to me.
The green is them.
Leading me to death.
I'm like so fast though they'll never get wait what do you
mean by that how am I already getting a caution you'll
destroy the yellow squadrons to start today yellow 13 I love
how they're always just like they can't be human
fast.
I was like, I don't know.
I don't need to be the hero.
I could leave.
I don't need to.
The Aether fleet is effectively immobilized.
You want me to go?
I'll go.
Unfortunately, our losses were high as well.
We now rely on your skills more than ever to compensate for
our losses.
You could be a hero like Big Bows.
Our losses were high as well.
We now rely on your skills more Oh my gosh, drop security.
A freeway under construction in a wheat field outside of
town.
When they started construction, I remember how the mayor
bragged about it.
No, I don't think the story is moving too fast.
Even though it would completely bypass our town.
I'll just ask questions when I don't understand.
The freeway became the occupation forces makeshift runway.
And the unfinished tunnels, their bunkers.
This was their base.
They were the elite flight squadron chosen to protect the
cannon.
Ironically, the same cannon that was created to shoot down
the asteroids became a catalyst to the war.
But when the Allied attacks no longer came, the squadron was
assigned long-range missions that took them to distant
battlefields.
Oh my god, I cannot read.
I thought of the words I would use to confront him.
I will try that thank you I think I actually knew that
before and I forgot although I harbored these feelings
within me I could never get close to him
his wingman was always by his side despite having a gentle
demeanor I could tell that the wingman would never allow
danger to get near yellow 13 even on land the pillar of
their group 13 exuded an air of invincibility he always
chose to a five-plane formation he was a man who prided
himself not on his kill record but on his record of never
losing a squadron member the Japanese the boy it's difficult
for me to describe just how good yellow 13s flying was I
think he has mixed feelings but I witnessed it once from the
ground he dies but I think he also kind of should have
turned the same arc with the same timing as the others yet
only his plane drew sharp contrails can you it's me I'm
like, his heart felt compassion towards the weaker enemies
he downed.
Someday, if a plane should have followed the others, but
instead it did 15 barrel rolls for no reason.
He would bear no resentment about being shot down.
He said this himself.
And so as time passed, I found the goodness of a home in
their company.
Leaving them was no longer an option for me now.
Oh.
Somewhere between revenge and admiration, I get it though.
Oh my gosh, let me save.
Let me save Invincible Fleet.
Am I going to be fighting them now?
Already?
Uh-oh.
How many missions are there, by the way?
We will launch a surprise attack on the Aether Fleet while
it lies immobilized and compromised.
Holy cow.
This large-scale airstrike will be the largest and the most
strategic operation since the transfer of HQ to North Point.
This is also a time mission.
Because this operation will be long in duration.
Okay, okay.
Remember, it is imperative that you complete the mission
objective and return to base safely.
I wish I would tell me how much time is given to me, you
know.
87 total.
Holy cow.
Is this similar to the one I just did?
Mint is one.
For this mission, if you happen to find the battleship
Tanager near the front of the naval evacuation line, sinking
it is canon.
I will do my bus just...
Ships give you the most points.
Good to know, good to know.
Probably will give us some...
New weapons then, I imagine.
Oh, well...
No new weapons!
Very cool.
Okay.
How long?
They said it was a longer mission, so they say that you
should refuel.
I think I might make this my last mission, though, for
today.
I was thinking...
I wanted to get to like halfway through them.
But we can... I think the game can probably take a couple
streams.
That's alright too.
Oh, new plane!
Yeah, let's check.
New aircraft though.
Oh!
Ah!
The A10!
My slow, slow...
Holy cow!
I wonder if we should try it.
Oh, I don't have enough money.
No!
I don't have enough money for it.
That's my Wart Hog!
Thank you for playing this combo!
Really nice, so this is why I work.
Curious about it is what got me to start playing.
Akoya, thank you.
I want my A10.
You like the face, yeah.
Newb.
Do we get enough points selling the F-16?
We could.
What if I sold the first plane instead, though?
Is it the F?
F4.
Oh, default aircraft cannot be sold.
Just kidding.
This gets us...
I can't read it.
Hold on.
One moment, please.
20...
Oh.
210,000.
I have a question.
When you sell the aircrafts, do you get your full money
back?
Because then I could just switch out, right?
Oh, you do.
That's so nice.
It is enough.
So, yeah.
What is the point?
Of 810 D's nuts.
You feel better?
You got that out of your system?
I.O., you feel really good about that one?
You feel...
feel, you feel satisfied now?
Sigh.
If you get, if you get the full amount of money back, what's
the point of like, I will sell it and then we can always get
it back, you know?
What's the other plane that you can buy?
Uh, hold on.
Sell.
It's it's only there's only one other thing it's the tiger
the f5 e f5 e Okay All right.
Oh wait this one's new
Tamar multi-role fighter Incorporates the latest technology
to compensate for delta wing design The Mirage, you love
what it is.
Plain though, you guys.
I can always switch.
So no...
Don't you worry.
If you're like, no, this one sucks.
I think I have to re-buy these, though.
That's the cluster bomb.
Unguided canister bomb, which pops open in mid-flight to
spawn multiple bomblets.
The bomblets.
Yeah, you have to buy new weapons per aircraft.
But it sells the other ones, too.
Cluster bomb is the goal.
Boomlets.
They call me a warrior.
I find me, though.
Thanks.
The UG.
It breathes in the air.
Why don't we try it?
Why not?
I think I'm not going to be good at aiming, though.
This might suck.
Unguided.
I don't know.
I feel like I need the guided for ships.
I think I'm going to sell them.
I think I already...
I think I...
Oh, whoops.
My bad.
I think I already regret my decision.
You don't need to aim it.
But I do...
A little.
Try them once.
Cluster bomb users can't aim either.
Yeah.
Let's sell.
Oh, wait.
Just kidding.
But, but, but.
Ew.
Sell.
Well.
Wait, but they're all unguided.
Wait.
Hold on.
Stop it.
Oh, now we go back to buy.
Because they're two different menus.
There we go.
We try.
I'm going to be so slow.
So slow.
Clusters don't need to be aimed.
But the boat score at least 3,000 points within the time
limit and continue to destroy enemy forces.
I just bear...
Oh my gosh.
Now it's...
Initiate attack.
All aircraft clear to engage any and all targets.
Sync the invincible Asia fleet while they're Where are the
boats?
You got any boats around here?
So dirty.
Are these boats?
These look like bridges.
Probably in the water.
You guys are so smart.
Why didn't I think of that?
There's hardly any resistance from the anchored ships.
You know, I feel like I pull a lot of my weight here and...
Everyone else doesn't do that.
These are the only ones that made it outside the harbor?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Mobius 1, he's on you!
Turn hard!
The other units are annihilated!
Oh my god, I'm gonna be a...
Holy...
One of ours took an artillery barrage.
Just a little carrier geophon sunk.
You...
All right.
Can I get back to the boats, please?
What are you?
Who are you down there?
Oh, you're...
Who are you?
I'm trying to target you.
This ship won't sink.
That's what they said about the Titanic!
You!
Enemy destroyer sunk.
Oh, wait.
Oh, nice.
Oh, my goodness.
Leave me alone, please.
I'm trying to get some votes.
Head's up.
Sam's on that carrier.
Still operational.
Hard enemy radar spike.
The music is so dramatic.
Battleship challenger sunk.
Bandit closing at six.
You guys are annoying me.
You're annoying me.
Yeah.
That's what I thought.
Yeah, they're like all on me.
I'm a sit and duck.
All my friends are gone.
Nobody's here to help me.
Nobody's here.
I need reinforcements.
Battleship damage are sunk.
No way!
Did I get them?
Where the hell am I?
Okay, let's go this way.
This way?
Oh, I see where I'm at, okay.
I could actually, maybe this is a good chance to refuel.
I think.
Maybe I should have.
Oh well.
It's fine.
What is the next target?
Oh, here, here, here.
Da-da!
Attack!
Oh, I'm out of.
Surface target destroyed.
I'm out of ammo.
Now's the chance.
Oh.
I think it's...
Keep an eye out around you.
That's all of ours in the way.
There's a lot of stuff down here.
I can always refuel.
I'm kind of like going away from it, so I'm like...
Save.
Destroyer Tiazzi sunk.
I'm so sorry.
Don't let them get out to sea.
Okay, I think I'm flying over those two things.
What's over here?
I am an A-10.
Yeah, I know.
I know what I am.
I'm a slow...
I'm a slow guy, okay?
I'm taking my time.
Oh, shoot.
I missed something.
It's so bright, I don't know.
This guy won't get off my butt.
They're sinking.
Hang in there.
Don't get off.
There he is.
Slow speed reverse.
Oh, that's right.
Yeah.
I'm like...
Okay, I think he's left me alone.
She's an A10 out of 10.
Okay, I need to keep working on the ground.
Where is this stuff anyway?
Oh, it's all behind me.
Okay, I'm right over top of it.
You!
Oh, shoot!
My bad.
I went kind of low.
I'm like, I'm like in these cities.
Can I please get something to go up?
I know.
Can you tell them to go away?
Can you do something about them?
I need to get over here.
And down.
Oh, oh my gosh.
I always fly right over top of it.
I can't see anything again.
I hate ground missions so much.
I hate them.
I'm not a fan.
Let me blow up the things in the air, please.
Like I can't see!
I can't see them!
Get lower.
I'm saying this way.
Mobius 1, Fox 2.
Ugh.
Enemy facility destroyed.
Miss.
Wait, over there.
There's some stuff.
Some cranes.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so busy dodging.
That I am unable to find my way around.
Please.
Ah!
I'm in a break, sir.
Shut up!
Give him the wiggles.
Wait.
Let's get this guy at least.
Maybe.
Yeah!
You annoying!
You are so annoying!
Okay.
We're halfway.
I wish I had...
Ouch!
Enemy facility destroyed.
I don't think I have enough time.
I don't think I have enough speed to...
To, um...
To go back, you know.
There's amphibious crap too!
Obius 1, Fox 2.
Enemy destroyer sunk.
Uh...
Plenty of time?
You think so?
Wonder...
I can... I can't read the mini-map.
I can't...
I can't read any map.
I need to go south.
Missile!
Oh, shoot.
There we go.
South.
Oh, this is west.
There we go.
I don't know, guys.
We'll try.
I'm so slow.
I got five minutes.
Maybe we can make it.
Maybe.
Maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe.
Meow, meow.
I want the other missile.
We might be good if we get those.
Get some stuff on the way.
Well, there's like nothing here.
Return to base.
No, sorry.
Yes.
Take off!
Okay, go!
We have no time!
Oh.
Uh, sure?
You're just hanging out over here?
I'm going upside down.
My very unconventional technique.
Radar lock.
Uh, yeah.
That didn't work.
Oh!
Wait, take down there.
Boats.
Best.
I did.
Ages.
All right, just a thousand more.
Just a thousand more points.
Sunk.
What's over here?
What is this down here?
All right.
Okay, let's step over here.
Go!
gosh they're so cool the way they like go down and then you
know they like shoot out and then like go down so fast all
right we're like safe over here for now so which is kind of
nice we're literally just cruising
oh sure surface target destroyed no no i was cruising i was
Cruising!
Oh, I was cruising!
Where is that guy?
Oh, is he above me?
He's so high!
Hi!
I'm like so high up too.
Wait, actually, how am I going?
I need to go down.
What am I looking at?
Am I looking at the sky?
That's the sky.
Is there anything else over here?
Let's go this way.
You, you.
A boat, a boat, a boat.
If you hit it and it hurts, it's dirt.
Got it.
Box two.
Oh, there's a lot over here.
AA guns destroyed.
Sam destroyed.
I'm okay.
I cannot see.
We're too high up.
Where is everything?
where is it all okay all right here we go some stuff dive
big yes they're all under me
come on oh i have 30 seconds oh there's no freaking way.
Wait, unless...
Ah!
There's no way!
I'm gonna get hit.
Oh, I was wondering why he was not multi-targeting!
I had the wrong missiles on!
AA guns destroyed!
Oh my god, there's no way.
There's no way.
Where is everything?
Ah!
She realized too late.
I did!
I was like, why is nothing?
Why is it?
I was like, I have multiple missiles ready!
Why?
Dang, okay.
All aircraft clear to engage any and all targets.
Sync the invincible Asia fleet while they're at anchor.
Good luck.
We'll head toward the back of the harbor.
what
i'm once again getting a little lost in the sauce but that's
okay part ships can't dodge so evil only dodge missiles if
launched that's what i was trying to do yeah all right let's
go guys oh
Please, please, please, let me get Tones first.
I think I just missed that.
Ow!
I'm taking a missile hit.
Full speed away from the harbor.
The other units are annihilated.
Oh!
Oh, you are a ship!
You are not, I mean, you are not a ship!
Oh, damn, I ate that.
I ate that.
Oh, dang.
I thought it was a...
I didn't realize it was a gun.
That guy is really going after me.
Because I'm stupid.
Oh, my gosh, please.
My brain.
Stop pressing the wrong buttons.
Alright.
Carrier Geophon sunk.
Enemy destroyer sunk.
Uh...
There's this... Wait, is this the one that...
Oh.
Uh...
Wait, oh, I'm just going...
I went to base on accident.
My bad.
Okay, we're fine.
Okay, get myself recentered though.
It's okay.
Honestly.
Oops.
Tanager!
Taken down!
Don't fly in a straight line.
Good rearm, very efficient.
It was, it was, it was on purpose, even.
Alright.
I lost it.
AA guns destroyed.
Okay.
I'm going after this crane.
Or something.
Maybe?
Oh, shoot.
Yes.
I'm going after the crane.
Come on, come on.
You too.
Go left here.
Really?
Are there more...
Are there more boats over this way?
Fox 2.
Looking for boats?
I see some.
Comberth Harbor in vector 290.
On the nose.
I wish I could use my flight suit.
above us
enemy destroyer sunk convivation cruiser fedris sunk evac
everyone evac everyone please I'm not trying to go high
alright is there anything no nothing over here.
Everything.
Over here.
Come on, come on.
Don't do that to me!
Don't do
that to me!
Shoot.
Screw you.
Screw you!
Um...
This BGM is so dramatic in Haro.
halfway there like how you're like oh my gosh
hold on sorry I'm gonna take a sippy oh I'm so sweaty I'm so
sweaty flying on I have 10 minutes left and we're halfway
there we're flying on a prayer
I need to get lower I know I'm trying to decide though The
other missiles make it so easy, you know what I mean?
Because we can get, like, so many at once.
Taking out a beer!
Don't throw in our ships!
Forget the small fry.
Concentrate on the larger ships.
Where are the large ships?
Are we clearly shooting?
Where are they?
Hard enemy radar spike.
Box 2.
Oh, sure.
Enemy cruiser sunk.
Uh, there's a...
No, we won't!
Uh, there's like that...
Is this the white dots right there?
That cruiser was worth 120 points?
Let's go.
There's one.
Wait, actually, I think that's a...
Yeah, that's an F-14.
Just kidding.
Oh my god!
Why do I keep pressing a square?
Missile shot trashed.
I'm so lost in the sauce at this point.
I'm so lost.
I get lost in the sauce, everybody.
I'm sorry.
And I'm lost here too?
No.
You know what?
I'm just gonna...
Box two, box two.
MGS three, muscle memory.
That wouldn't that be so bad?
I get the issue, though, with this game that I play for too
long and I actually, like, start...
I actually, not just this game, with a lot of games.
I, like, start losing my ability to use think, you know?
Destroyer.
Take it out, please.
Like, I'll be fine, and then I'm not.
Fatiguing the defaults, they got older skills.
It could be!
I'm gonna leave this place.
We'll go somewhere else.
I don't like it anymore.
We're gonna find more boats in the ocean, or something.
I only have seven minutes, though.
I mean, only seven minutes, it's still a lot of time.
I wish I, maybe I should go get the other.
My plane's hanging in there.
I think I'll make it back.
Good job, friend.
Haven't seen any big action in a while.
I love this voice acting.
Surface target destroyed.
I'm heading to nowhere.
Ancient trouble.
Returning to base.
The guy's so funny.
Let's go for the Sam.
Don't get me.
Don't come after me.
I know that's what you're doing.
Please, can I get signal?
Can I get towed?
Sam destroyed.
Destroyer Tiazzi sunk.
Oh, shoot.
This is all land, though.
I wonder if I should go back to the sea.
Hi!
Wreck this place!
Please, leave me alone.
This is how they feel.
feel when I'm shooting them, huh?
Evade.
Please, I'm destroyed!
Where am I?
Where am I going?
I'm around.
I was just following the land.
Ugh.
God.
Put me out of my way.
Submarine!
Hi!
Can I get a tone?
Did I miss?
I'm...
I didn't get anything!
My speed is so slow.
Maybe I won't.
Maybe I...
Honestly, I don't even know if I notice a difference between
the A10 and how I was playing before, you know?
Wait, did I miss?
Oh my gosh.
Subs are inside a hangar.
Where is...
Don't let them get out to see.
We got that.
There's a hangar.
Oh wait, there's something here.
There's one here.
What is that?
Get that, get that.
Don't let them go out to sea.
Yeah!
Ooh, that was worth the big money.
Amphibious craft.
Where am I?
Don't let them escape from the harbor.
Maybe here?
Submarine.
No, no, no.
Come on, Tom.
Oh, there's a mist because they're inside.
Ah, I see, I see, I see.
That's what you guys meant by the hangar.
But does the hangar not blow up?
Does the hangar not...
Target the transport ship.
I know you told me that, but I didn't realize that the
hangar wasn't, like, already blown up.
That's what I meant.
Get out of there.
Hard enemy radar spike.
Oh, I don't know if that was that long, yeah.
The hangar doesn't blow up?
Oh, so I have to wait for them to leave.
Is that what it is?
We better approach anyway.
Focus on other targets.
I can't even find anything.
Oh, I hate these missions so much.
These are the ones, they don't tilt me, but they make me,
like, just frustrated to play.
Mobius 1, Fox 2.
Wait, there's another one.
Because everything is so hard to see.
It's harder than what it seems.
I'm just trying to get the...
Okay, I can't play the Warthog.
I can't do it.
Oh, it's... I need to get the damn submarine right here.
I can't freaking find it.
I know I am a tank, though.
Isn't it great?
I took that right to the face and I'm only at 39% damage.
Okay, here we go.
There we go.
Little guy right there.
Blow him up.
Hard enemy radar spike.
Submarine Beowulf high sunk.
Did it?
Did it shoot?
Oh, it did.
Oops.
Oh.
Don't let it go over to these cranes, I suppose.
Wait, is that another sub right there?
Hard enemy radar spike.
I think it's a down sub, maybe?
I have 30 seconds to get 500 more points.
I don't see it happening, but...
Nice try, I suppose.
That was a sub.
Wait, that was a sub.
Wait.
Go back.
That's a crane.
Oh, so close.
So close.
Wait, quit mission.
Let's try it with my...
Oh.
Too slow, too tricky.
Too tricky, unfortunately.
Too tricky for how I play, maybe.
I tried.
Everything, everything is just...
The graphics makes it so hard to play.
Mike Tyson, thank you!
Nah, and it's okay.
I'm learning eventually, you know?
back.
It's a bit harder to look at.
Oh, it gets much better in later games.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Um, wait, do I need to buy?
You.
Yes.
Alright.
Oh, nope, that's not what I meant to press.
Let's do this!
First try.
What mission are we on?
Six.
Initiate attack.
All aircraft clear to engage any and all targets.
Sync the invincible Asia fleet while they're at anchor.
already what do you mean engine trouble watch out for a a
fire already okay so i guess okay the ships are are they the
dots like the big white dots
bro ate a bird right yes okay
focus on red dots i don't see any red dots do you guys see
red dots you guys see red dots are you seeing they look
orange do you mean the orange dots orange dots orange dots
carrier geophon suck
Beluga sunk.
Hard enemy radar spike.
Battleship Tanager sunk.
Okay, we're empty.
I'm turning around.
South.
Hard enemy radar spike.
I'm gonna go refuel.
Or I will once I can.
We're returning to base.
Ha ha ha!
all right let's go i know we're so nimble ah it feels so
good all right oh what's down here wait is that tanager one
enemy destroyer to the front and left enemy destroyer sunk
so many guys I'm coming at.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Yee-hoo!
Oh, I missed.
That's fine.
Um, oh.
Did I get
him?
Yes.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oops.
Mid-attack coffee.
break on the ground.
All right, let's go down this way.
I see an orange.
Blinky orange, blinky orange.
I'm on my way.
Blinky orange.
Yes.
Enemy destroyer sunk.
Where did they shoot from me from?
Uh.
Tanager made it out of the harbor!
You?
Am
I...
I'm headed southwest.
Maybe?
I'm gonna go restock again, I think.
I'm kind of far, but...
I'm gonna go restock again.
We still have 11 minutes.
Just restock, yeah.
I'm fast enough where I feel like I am okay to go do it, you
know what I mean?
The manager was already stuck.
Approaching point of return.
Maintain current course.
okay I'm skipping and I'm taking off we have no time to
waste we have no time to waste all right let's go there's a
few more that we can do this way friend what are you doing
out here they come what are you doing I don't think you're
pulling your weight, Mr. Tana Jirtune.
Electric Boogaloo.
I'll fly this somehow.
That is your job.
I don't want...
No, no, no.
Destroyer.
Yeah, yeah.
That's what...
Oh, sure.
But I want this guy.
Wait, it's the shield!
Oh, that was so close.
Holy cow, I just wanted to take the hit.
I wanted to take the hit!
Something over here.
Oh, this one.
What's wrong with me?
Come on, where is he?
I think that's it.
And then...
Yes.
Oh, there, there he is.
Ah!
All right.
Come on.
Come on!
Take the shot!
Whoa!
I got hit, guys.
I got hit.
Yahoo!
I'm going back.
Oh boy.
I'm going south!
Southwest!
all right going back to refuel it's so much easier with
these next environment yeah I think we got all the orange in
that area let's pull up you also get repaired no kid oh my
gosh you really do Mobius one you are clear Alright.
Let's go, baby.
Burning through that fuel.
That's what it's meant to be burned through, no?
Let's go!
We'll go to the corner.
Well, actually, what if they want me to go back home?
Combat's not limited to this area alone.
Keep an eye out around you.
I pass over these guys.
Yeah, we're so close.
Seven minutes.
700 points.
So here's the BVVV, thank you!
Thank you so much!
We are ignoring the small...
The small fries at the moment.
Somewhere.
That's a high value target.
Oh shoot, wait, those are inside.
I destroyed something!
Oh, there's one.
Oh, we got a...
What happens if they get out to sea?
What's the issue?
Come on, get off my ass, please.
Okay.
Break,
break, break.
Sam destroyed.
Yeah.
They just escape, I guess.
Oh, maybe.
There's not one guy in the river.
Oh, wait.
No, please.
These guys right here, right here, right here.
Can't shake it.
Enemy facility destroyed.
These are just cranes, but I'll take them out anyway.
Uh...
Oh, I'm going the wrong way.
I'm going the wrong way.
Okay, five minutes.
400 points.
I think they were in here.
Leave me alone!
You're... you're throwing off my shot!
I don't think that's gonna get him.
Destroyer.
Where is he?
Is it him?
Wait, where's the destroyer?
Am I on him?
Under me.
Yeah, I'm trying.
Where is he?
Oh.
Look for the orange dot.
Please, please.
Did I get him?
Oh, good.
We got him.
Destroyer!
I might have got him.
I don't know, actually.
Oh my gosh, we're so close.
Can we please, like, ah.
Oh, oops.
I wouldn't have gotten him anyway.
Under...
Underwear!
No,
friend!
No!
Don't go down!
That's so...
That's so stupid.
Pick up the weak ones first.
Can I...
Oh my god, everybody is under me.
This sucks.
Okay, I need to get a little bit more.
Ah, ah shoot.
Can I...
Everybody is so...
Everybody is below me!
Ah!
Wait.
I'm pivoting, I'm pivoting, I'm pivoting.
We're going over to this area.
This area is cursed for me.
Newcomb Earth Harbor.
Infector 320.
On the nose.
It's in the way.
Sink it.
Enemy vessel sunk.
Fox 2.
I just need one more.
I think that's it.
Yo!
Give me that storage.
Give me the storage.
Give me the crane.
Yeah!
Okay.
Yahoo!
We did it, everybody!
Don't get sucked down with them.
We stopped two minutes.
Wait, I'm gonna get that guy.
Makeup points.
Nya-ha-ha-ha.
Nya-ha-ha.
Where?
Who is getting me?
We've got to get out of the harbor.
We're here to come to Slardberg's side.
The ship's without ammo are useless.
Obius 1, Fox 2.
Splash 1, Splash 1!
Splash 1!
Just head south?
Okay.
A girl can't have fun flying around.
Blowing things up.
Fine.
Yeah, there's more ships.
Go back and rearm if you're low on ammo.
Ooh.
Sanitize my six o'clock omega-5.
Sanitize my six o'clock.
What if I want to get the cruiser?
What about that guy right there?
Oh, that's a crane.
I thought it was a ship.
Surface target destroyed.
Oh yeah, I get it.
every crane i'm gonna make it so that they hate they can't
do any work they're gonna they're gonna be like oh man i
really need to lift this heavy machinery but i can't because
that dang guy destroyed all of my cranes
sky eye here enemy fleet and harbor facilities confirmed
destroyed yippee yeah Mission complete.
All aircraft, RTB.
RTB.
Yay!
Oh well, gotta take the day off.
Woohoo!
Yay!
It really, it really, sometimes you really do just gotta
change the plane.
Oh, whoops, sorry.
Their plans for invading North Point have been delayed
indefinitely.
Although we are still far from triumphant, this victory gave
our troops a much needed boost in morale.
Can't wait for my merch to get through customs, meanwhile,
the crane eater.
This victory gave our troops a much needed boost in morale.
Matthias, captain of the Tanninger, successfully evacuates
most of the crew and becomes a hero later to appear in Ace
Combat 7's DLC editions.
Where does the captain, what game does he show up in?
He, he, he, he, he was a smart one.
Oh, wait, just the DLC.
Oh, okay, okay.
That's funny.
He doesn't really show up before 7.
That's so funny.
I haven't played the DLC, actually, so.
Yippee!
Nice.
Oh, 7 plushies.
Lost in the store.
Thank you so much for that Tony.
Thank you!
Deep Strike, Mission 7.
See what kind of mission it is.
Your next mission is to attack the solar power generator
plants in the Faith Park region.
These generators equal nuclear ones in output and provide
about 60% of the energy for the illusion's
military-industrial complexes.
require oil or uranium supplies, we cannot stop power
production by interdicting their supply lines.
This deep strike mission will not only cripple the erosion's
industrial output, but also divert attention from our own
imminent invasion plans.
Oh, sorry, oh, we have invasion plans?
Oh, right, right, right, we have our invasion plans.
We have invasion plans.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got it.
Yes!
Yeah, ours, our...
This mission...
Oh, geez.
Well...
I'm gonna do a second save.
There you go.
We shall do it next time!
Next time, next time.
Yes!
Yeah, our invasion plans.
Yeah, I knew that we had those.
And we...
We knew that already.
Oh, it's this mission.
Oh, that always makes me feel really, really good when
people say that.
Like, oh, gosh, it's this much.
Thank you, streamer, Minto.
Thank you, Bueller.
Thank you.
I imagine if there's 18 missions, probably two more streams.
Ish.
Yeah, I would like to get it done in two more streams, so...
Um...
Now what is that?
Hold on.
I'm thinking.
Sounds right.
Six missions each is good.
Yeah, because that would be six...
Yeah, six...
Yeah.
The game shows its age.
But...
I wouldn't say...
I would say the most frustrating part is that the graphics
of my dog.
I don't think the game plays badly or poorly.
I think, uh, it's not, like I said, I dislike the the
air-to-ground missions, like the ones that we just did.
Just because I don't think they're as fun as the dog fights.
But that's just my opinion, you know?
Like, they just, I like the dog fights so much, so...
It's a great Hey DomtonAmito, effectively your first time
playing again and you got it quick.
Yeah, I feel like I've been picking it up better than
before.
I think I struggled so much the first time I played 7.
Deep clicking to the stream as well.
Thanks!
Of course.
That's what I'm here for.
I hate the destroy stuff missions.
Yeah!
So...
For its age it holds up really well.
I would say so.
I would say it does hold up very well for its age.
And it is fun.
It's definitely very fun.
So thanks for the stream.
It was cool to watch how quickly I've been adapting to the
aerial combat.
Hope you have a great evening and pleasant dreams.
I bet you're going to dream about flying tonight.
I will be aboard.
I want to maybe see if I can.
Maybe if I can tinker with my flight stick.
Or maybe if I can find someone like local.
to Tinker with Flight Stick, you know what I mean?
I kind of feel like playing Ace Combat now.
Is 7 a good place to start?
I think so.
I mean...
I...
So...
Here is my take on Ace Combat.
There is a story.
Right?
Of course there's a story.
But when you are telling somebody to start at Metal Gear
Phantom, pain it feels much different than well i would say
even phantom pain does not have as much story as like the
first four metal gears you know what i mean like metal gear
is so story focused i feel like ace combat yes and no you
know what i mean like you can join if you don't care about
if you just want to play plain game you can just obviously
like play ace combat seven and not to anything that
anybody's saying and you won't you won't understand like you
know everything but yeah they can all be played standalone
for sure you're gonna miss some references but um like with
metal gear if you can if you skip the cut scenes obviously
it's the same experience but and sorry i know i'm comparing
it to metal gear but that's just because like it's it's you
know Like, oh, I want to play Metal Gear, where do I start?
Oh, well, you start at the beginning, though.
But, um, for these.
That's why I'm starting at 4, because I do want to
understand more of the backstory of everything.
If you need more information and help, I recommend you check
on YouTube for Ace Combat Tutorials.
I hope I can help you as much as I can.
Thanks, Nen!
If I have time, I will, between streams.
I think Ace Combat 7 is, um, oh, it plays so, oh, Chad is
frozen again, thank you, it plays so well, and the music is
so great, and it's just a, it's a really, it's a really good
game, I'm so excited for Ace Combat 8, every game leads up
to Ace Combat 3 in the timeline, so you'll see more and more
overt references to Ace 3, oh, okay, but which Resident Evil
game to play first.
Okay, that is out of my...
You're going out of my scope of knowledge.
Yes!
If you need...
Someone put it in the in the
comments.
But 4, 5, 0, 6, 7, 3.
I wonder where 8 will fall then.
Wait, this is so fascinating.
If...
Wait, if you want some great jet fighter video game keynote,
look up Captain Skyhawk made by Rare and published by Milton
Bradley.
8 is after 7 but before 3.
Between 7 and 3.
Can't believe you just glossed over the subplot of Liquid
F-15 and Revolver Barrage a lot?
Yeah.
Sorry, my bad.
Mirage or what?
Revolver.
So far, I plan on playing the games I listed.
Like, four, what is it?
Four, five, zero, six, seven, and eight.
Three I would like to play eventually.
We'll see, though.
But, um...
Those are the games I plan on playing for now.
Stop it!
I have to... What do you want me to not count?
Do you want me to never count again?
People are speculating eight might be after seven, but
before three.
Three keeps getting closer and closer.
I don't know how they'll tackle it.
I'm so excited to play three.
Because it just sounds so like wackadoodle compared to
everything else.
After 4, all the later games will play like 7.
Because if you don't...
Didn't know 4 was actually the last game for old-school Ace
Combat title.
Oh, actually, I didn't know that.
Good to know.
Roku Nana!
But yeah.
7 2019.
8.
20 29.
2040s.
Wait, but then we are really getting so close.
That's fun.
That's so fun.
So she'll say it as in Japanese.
One, two, three, four, five.
Roku Nana.
Eight, nine, ten.
This is how we will teach all the children numbers from now
on.
Okay.
9 will be a remake of 7 because 7, 8, 9 1,
2, 3, 4, 5 Roku Nana 8, 9, 10 I'm so stupid don't laugh why
can't you guys say minus 2 why can't you guys say minus 2
when it's a bad thing when I do good jokes you guys say
minus 2 and here you laugh why do you laugh no Plus two!
No!
All right guys, well thank you so much for the part one of
Ace Combat for... and, um, I hope you had a good time.
It's fun really, it's really fun getting back into this.
Sorry if I made you motion sick at any point.
I apologize.
If I made you motion sick at any point, my barrel rolling.
Non-stop.
I mean, there was always a plus two in my book.
It was a fun stream.
It's okay.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a good night?
Have a good time, Joan!
I'll see you when I haunch you next!
Yaha!
Outsubito!
Outsubito, outsubito!
I'm sorry!
Oh!
I wish I wasn't hungry enough to eat!
Guys,
I wish I wasn't hungry enough to eat.
And I could do too much.
I was going to take off a day on Monday.
Maybe I'll just play more Iskomba instead.
But I need a day off.
No, I don't.
I don't have to take a day off.
I could play more Iskomba on Monday.
This is rest.
It's actually not.
It's actually quite like...
It's quite stressful.
But at the same time.
what i mean i'll think about it take a day off sick you i
feel great right now because i took medicine i might stream
ascribe on monday i might do more on monday oh wait i was no
i can do that i was i need to go shopping for some stuff
because next week i'm also doing a hand cam where i'm making
you know remember when i made puppets uh halloween puppets
i'm doing that again but i'm making densetsu puppets like
hand puppets so hand cam next week so it's not all games I
was trying not to make it like like the same schedule as
this week because I have Tomodachi life and I have Pragmata
I'm like playing so many games that I'd like have multiple
parts you know like Tomodachi life and Pragmata and well I
didn't get to do deadly premonition this week but I have it
next week and then ace combat and then maybe ace combat
again I was thinking of maybe doing deadly permonition like
three days in a row oh wait i don't know i might be tired
after the concert on saturday oh yeah i'm looking at my
schedule right now
the games will wait for you that's true i kind of want to
just mic is on no way really i just think like want to get
through some of these games too at the same time so i'm like
hmm
what it's on no way sorry i just like yapping i think maybe
i feel like i should just show up on the screen at this
point i show up for me don't not the game do what you feel
like really
I still am making my schedule for next week, so...
Really?
For a little old me?
You'd show up for a little old me?
You'd show up for a little old Minky.
I haven't checked Tomodachi life today.
I'm scared too.
I'm scared too What if I check and I need to do a gorilla
live
I wanted to make sure Thank you I appreciate it so much
Thanks for looking out for me I don't think I would say this
much though If I didn't think I'm literally talking to you
You I'm talking to you
I'm talking to you I'm talking to you
Me?
We are part of our story.
We are.
You.
Dance at you.
EXE.
We are
part of our story.
Atashi?
Wow.
That's so cute of you to call yourself Atashi.
Atashi?
being why what are you being so cute for who are you trying
to be so cute for
i'll end the stream once i forget the lyrics to the what i
forget or once i don't remember the lyrics to jibu the rest
of of the jibu